hey welcome to an ALT shift X live
stream to discuss House of the Dragon
episode 2 the Rogue Prince and oh my
goodness isn't caraxi's just fantastic
he's so squeaky he's just flying around
like a big [ __ ] Sky eel just making
all these weird sounds and and and he's
so [ __ ] up and wonderful and I love
him I there was a great Dragon showdown
between karaxi's and Cyrax the dragons
of Daemon and rainy era and it was
really cool seeing them interact I think
there are definitely succeeded in
differentiating the dragons giving them
their own personalities and their own
sounds of course they should have their
own sounds so that we can recognize
these Dragons by voice because these
dragons are going to be very important
in the story and the individual
personalities and their individual is
are important so that's really cool to
see
viserys King viserys has continued to
make some uh catastrophically bad
decisions he announced that he wants to
marry Alice and Hightower which pisses
off Corliss and rainies the valerions
because they wanted King viserys to
marry their daughter Elena it pisses off
rhaenyra because now her dad is marrying
her best friend and neither her friend
or her dad told her this was going to
happen so rhaenyra is unhappy
um viserys is managing to just annoy
everybody
um and so Daemon and
and Lord call us went and had their own
party on on driftmark at at corliss's
house and they said hey if viserys is
going to reject us we're going to do our
own thing we're going to fight this crab
guy
yeah crabs in the chat because uh the
crab feeder we got a good Glimpse uh of
him at the end of the episode looks like
he's being set up as a big Baddie uh and
it's going to be very fun to see Daemon
and call us take on the crab feeder
so he's called he's called The Crab
feeder uh because he likes to tie his
prisoners to the beach so that they are
consumed by the crabs I think in the
book it says that the crab feeder you
know he ties them to the beach and then
uh the people are like drowned When the
tide comes in uh but the show is
emphasizing more the uh being eaten
alive by crabs part which is
um you know that's also fun
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Busan
poos who says we got a drama walk in the
garden yeah that was something that used
to happen a lot in the old Game of
Thrones original show
um we had you know the queen of thorns
walking with Tywin and jabbing at each
other
except in this case it was a very
uncomfortable courtship walk between uh
King viserys Targaryen and the 12 year
old Lena valarion who were being sort of
pushed together for a potential
political marriage and I loved the
performances from both of them here like
viserys was so deeply visibly
uncomfortable like just just his faces
just his Expressions just his body
language was so perfect just going like
oh I just really don't like courting
this 12 year old I would so much rather
caught this 17 year old or however old
Alison is meant to be but yeah the scene
with the scene with Lena was great and
they made some changes with Lena in
terms of her relationship with dragons
and I won't like spoil anything
um these streams we're not going to
spoil future episodes in these live
streams
um Elena showed an interest in Vega so
vegar is the biggest dragon in the world
currently after Valerian the black dread
diet vegar is now the biggest in the
world it was originally the dragon of
Queen visenya aegon the conqueror's
sister wife
and Vega is now not in King's Landing
not in the control of the targaryens
Vega has made a home out on the coast of
the narrow sea somewhere this giant
dragon the biggest most dangerous living
thing in the world is just like having a
holiday on the beach and the targaryens
aren't even control aren't even in
control of it which is terrifying it's
like if if one of your like big nuclear
weapons just flew off and started doing
its own thing and I love Lena's like
sympathy and interest in Vega apparently
the the people at spice town which is a
town on driftmark the Valerian Island uh
the valerion you know the Valerian
workers are hearing Vega singing they
hear her song at times and it's a sad
song so so I I love the fact that you
know Elena has this interest in Vega and
just this sadness of this lonely giant
old dragon sitting on the beach just
crying and being lonely and Lena having
Sympathy For That uh I really like that
is an addition that isn't in the books
but but I think it's really good overall
I'm really impressed with what this show
is doing because you know the book only
gives a very general outline of the
basic events and all the dialogue all
the relationships all the details are
all being filled in and invented by the
show and I think mostly they're making
really good decisions I'm pretty
impressed so far
thank you for the Super Chat from Dopey
Dragon who says tell me about the crab
feeder yeah okay so as I said you know
the crab feeder is being set up as this
bad guy for Daemon and Corliss to face
this fella here is krag ass crab feeder
so he's the leader of the triaki or
a-leader of the triarchy which is this
Alliance of tyroshly Elise and Mir which
are these Eastern cities not in Westeros
but but right next to Westeros
um and crab feeder we don't know much
about him in the books we just know that
he's a pretty brutal military leader
um I'm really I am really interested in
this mask I there's no answer in the
books about like why he wears the mask
and like what his deal is but like if I
chose to make up my own headcanon if I
were to speculate I like like what if
the crab feeder what if the reason he
wears a mask and his skin is all [ __ ]
up like look on his shoulder like his
skin is all [ __ ] up I like to imagine
that what if the crab feeder himself got
trapped or tied down or got stuck on a
beach somehow and a bunch of crabs
started eating his flesh what if the
crab feeder himself was fed on by crabs
and it drove him a bit crazy and it like
messed up his face so he wears a mask to
hide how his face was disfigured by the
crabs
um and he now chooses to like inflict
that suffering that he experienced on
his enemies as a sort of a cruel messed
up you know emotional reaction to how he
suffered that that's how that's what I
like to imagine maybe he suffered from
the crabs now he makes everyone else
suffer
um that's a good bad guy backstory isn't
it but yeah like we don't know much
about him in the books so it's going to
be really interesting to see how they
characterize him
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
beesman and from Little Dak who says not
a fan of the original Game of Thrones
theme being used in intro they should
have used a different theme I agree
little duck
um so we got a brand new opening theme
for this show uh well a brand new
opening sequence with the same music
which I I did find disappointing like I
was looking forward to getting a brand
new uh piece of music to make this show
yeah like its own distinct thing
um so yeah I was disappointed we didn't
get new music and honestly I don't love
this new opening sequence now that like
what it is is we see this like River of
blood we see this bloodline as it passes
through these sort of circular nodes and
it like splits and reconnects and what
this is this is like a visual
representation of a family tree of the
bloodline of House Targaryen because it
starts with like the Doom of valyria the
then aegon the Conqueror and his two
sons and then it goes to johary son like
joharis's one splits into nine streams
of blood because uh King joharis had
nine children who survived to adulthood
and then we have like uh Amon and Balon
so it all corresponds to the family tree
um if you check here like this is this
is what the opening sequence does it
starts with aegon and his two sons and
it goes to joheras and then they have
nine kids then aemon and Balon die and
then it goes to viserys and then it goes
to Rainier except in the background of
the opening sequence there is like
another bloodline off on the side
somewhere that's also doing its thing
which I guess represents like rhaenys
and her kids and her bloodline uh so so
it's it's the family tree it's the royal
family lineage represented visually and
I think the blood you know like it makes
sense as a symbol because just like in
episode one they were highlighting the
interconnectedness of life and death we
had the Emma Aaron giving birth on the
birthing bed at the same time that the
warriors were fighting each other and
killing each other on the tourney
grounds and so this idea of like life
and death are connected
um the danger of power like blood as in
like family lineage blood is in genetics
blood is in like the blood of the Dragon
runs thick Daemon said last episode so I
think like I think in theory this
opening sequence makes sense I think
blood makes sense as a symbol as a motif
and I think that showing the family tree
so that people can sort of locate you
know where we are in the story because
like the family is going to change as
the story goes on this season covers 30
years there's a bunch of time jumps so I
imagine that this family tree might
update as new people come into the story
um but so so I think the sequence makes
sense in theory but I don't think it
works all that well in practice because
I think that most people aren't going to
recognize like what these nodes are
meant to represent like like what people
won't interpret this as a family tree I
think I think a lot of people this will
be too abstract for a lot of people and
also it just doesn't look that good like
I'm just seeing a lot of gray stone it
just it just doesn't look interesting
the Graystone so so yeah I mean
personally I'm not a huge fan of the
opening sequence but that's what it is
it's a family tree
thanks for the Super Chat from Sam who
says great episode Millie Alcock did
great I love the valyria model it's as
if Biden had a model train set in his
bedroom maybe he does thanks to the
Super Chat from Red Flannel guy who says
Daemon defending his brother gave me
chills yeah well that's what's so
interesting about you know Daemon and
viserys right like Daemon is so
frustrated that viserys doesn't trust
him more and work with him more and is
frustrated that you know he feels like
viserys doesn't think he's good enough
to be Heir and doesn't you know give him
the acknowledgment make him hand he
doesn't give him what he wants but at
the same time Dame and you know Damon
causes so much trouble for viserys but
Daemon also clearly loves and respects
viserys and he doesn't want anyone else
to [ __ ] with viserys Daemon will [ __ ]
with viserys but Daemon doesn't want
anyone else to mess with this heiress uh
which I really enjoy
um and the way that viserys caused
trouble this episode I I thought was
fantastic and really fun
um because that also was a change uh
from
a change from the books because they
made it so that
Daemon has so so this episode is set six
months after episode one and apparently
Daemon that whole time instead of going
to runestone in the veil which is what
viserys told Daemon to do last episode
Daemon has instead gone to Dragonstone
the sort of ancestral home of House
Targaryen and he's been hanging out with
mazaria there and he's brought a bunch
of the gold clerks the city watch of
King's Landing and just made them his
personal Army and guards and just
brought them to Dragonstone and he's
just been living on Dragonstone in
defiance of the king which is really
important symbolically because the title
The Prince of Dragonstone is
traditionally the title of the heir to
the Iron Throne so Daemon is occupying
the symbolic seat of the heir to the
throne even though viserys named
rhaenyra as the heir to the throne so
Daemon is just openly defying uh King
viserys but then he makes it
considerably worse
um when all of a sudden Daemon declares
I'm going to marry mazaria despite the
fact that he's already married so Dame
on takes a second wife and he calls
himself Heir and he steals a dragon egg
specifically the the dead baby Prince
balon's dragon egg so that dragon egg is
symbolic of the heir to the throne
because it was given to Baby Balon or it
was going to be given to Baby Balon who
was going to be out of the throne so
like Daemon has very loudly challenged
and undermined viserys's legitimacy and
rhaenyra's being Heir through his
announcements
and that's not in the book like like
it's it's sort of like that in the book
but he goes much further in the show
which I think is a really cool
escalation which then leads to this
confrontation at Dragonstone so I
thought that was really cool thanks for
the Super Chat from WB who says are
there any notable technological
advancements between House of the dragon
and Game of Thrones or is Westeros just
stuck in the technological mud that's an
interesting question
um I don't I can't think of any like
technological changes that really happen
in the timeline no
um I've heard all sorts of you know
speculations about like maybe you know
gunpowder doesn't exist in Westeros
because the minerals and chemicals to
make it don't exist in the world of
Westeros in the same way that they exist
here and Etc I mean one of the
interesting things about like the
setting of A Song of Ice and Fire is
that the world is full of these castles
and ruins and edifices that are very
ancient but which
um
[Music]
are much bigger than what they have now
like the wall is this gigantic
incredible edifice like how could you
possibly make the wall
um and Storm's end like Storm's end is
an ancient ancient castle and yet
Storm's end is huge and it's like well
how did they how did they build it it
seems as though if anything technology
may have been better in the past than it
is in the present it seems as though
technology technology has actually gone
backwards in the history of Westeros in
a lot of ways
and you could say that well maybe that's
related to the long night you know like
what like Westeros is almost
post-apocalyptic it's gone backwards
because there was you know there was the
age of Heroes and then there was like a
downfall in the long night
um that there are all these ruins all
across essos uh some of which are
related to like the Doom of valyria and
the century of blood all of these white
cities are ruins and some of them were
like wiped out by the Dothraki and stuff
but like like there is a sense of
decline you know like the there was the
great Valyrian Empire that fell there
was a shy which seems to have been like
possibly the seat of a great Empire that
fell so it seems as though technology
may have gone backwards in Westeros not
forwards
um partly because of the Apocalypse of
the White Walkers and the apocalypse the
tomb of valyria so yeah it's an
interesting question thanks to the super
jet from Sid and from Taylor who says
realizing Otto Hightower is Danny deck
chair has melted my brain pray for me
thanks for the donation from wall who
says I feel like these episodes are
moving too fast can compared to the
story building in early God thoughts
they are moving quick they are moving
quick
um like we jumped six months ahead
um I I think that
I think that they're moving fast
currently because there's a lot of
backstory to cover and the backstory
sort of takes place over a long time
like that's why we had the council at
harrenhal and then we had you know the
death of Emma and and balon's death and
then we had the Rainier as air and now
we've got viserys saying he's going to
marry Alison
um I imagine that the pace is probably
going to slow down
once we get to the important stuff that
starts happening
um but yeah they are moving fast I think
I think they're being efficient like
it's it's I think that they're not like
skipping over anything I think that they
are laying the important groundwork but
we'll see how the pace continues thanks
to the super chats from Philippe who
says first live stream thanks for the
donation from James who says I like that
we get to see that grand maester Melos
and Lionel strong aren't just Otto's
puppets like pycell was for Tywin and
we'll take stances even if they go
against his ambition yeah I mean we did
see Melos being sort of like a puppet
for Otto I think in this scene though
um we saw some very interesting glances
between Melos and Otto when viserys
brought up the suggested marriage
between
um
viserys and Lena
there was a very significant glance
where is it
yeah these guys look at their face so
great so viserys just said oh Carla said
I should marry Lena and look at
Melissa's face he's like oh that's not
that's not our plan that's not what we
want and there were some very
significant glances between Otto and
Melos throughout as they masterfully
manipulated viserys against marrying
Lana like Otto and Melos sort of working
together subtly we're both saying oh
yeah Lena yeah that look maybe you
should marry Elena but oh you know
rhaenyra wouldn't like that and oh you
know isn't that kind of an insult to the
memory of your dead wife Emma like oh so
they so they managed to sound like
they're being encouraging and unbiased
but really what what Otto and Melos are
doing is trying to convince viserys not
to marry Elena because Otto wants
viserys to marry his daughter Allison
and Melos seems to be in on that like we
saw a lot of sort of subtle
cooperation between Otto and Melos like
in last episode as well
Otto handed this letter to Melos descend
and we don't know what the letter says
but you know that's clearly a connection
between Otto and Melos and that makes
sense because the Citadel of the
maesters where Melos represents uh is in
Old Town which is the city that the
hightower's rule and there's lots of
speculation about some kind of
conspiracy between the high towers and
the maesters
um so you know at the very least it
seems like there is cooperation there
yeah thanks for the Super Chat from
person who says do you have a particular
fear for how the show might go mine is
that they will try to make someone the
good guy at the end yeah well I don't
want to spoil anything about the ending
um I think that they
oh I mean it's just weird because like
the way that the story is written in the
books it is so sparse like that we
definitely are going to have very
different feelings about these
characters in the show
compared to the book just because we
know so much more about them in the show
like in the book we don't really get to
find out all that much about people's
inner motivations and their and their
emotions so I think it's inevitable that
there are going to be big differences
between the show and the book
um and I think that's inevitable and I
think that's fine I think that's the way
it should be I think that what is
important is that I I agree that I don't
want there to be any one good guy and
one bad guy like I like George has said
and Ryan Condell has said the
co-creators of this show that they want
people to have different opinions about
who's good who's bad they want people to
have they want it to be subjective they
want it to be ambiguous they want it to
be they want people to debate who they
side with so I I so based on that it
doesn't sound like they're gonna make it
too simplistic
thanks for the Super Chat from Payton
who says pretty impressive how many bad
decisions viserys was able to make in
one episode yeah he he did a shockingly
bad job didn't he I but it's so funny
because like viserys in so many ways is
trying to do the right things like
viserys says for example you know I
don't want to start a war I don't want
to attack the stepstones if I don't have
to my job as king is to avoid war and
it's like well yeah that that sounds
good in theory like a king shouldn't
start wars that get people killed but
you know callus is making this point
that if you don't stand up to challenges
and threats the crown appears weak and
then you'll get more challenges and more
threats and more instability
um and you know also we saw viserys
asking advice from his counselors a lot
what is your advice dear Otto like
viserys listens genuinely to the people
around him uh except for rhaenyra um
which is a good thing right you want a
King who listens you want a king who
wants peace you want a king who like
does these things and tries to cooperate
and tries to do all the right stuff but
like it is tragic that despite his good
intentions and despite trying to do the
right things
um viserys just sort of manages to [ __ ]
everything up and you know deciding to
marry Allison is
sort of like the first time that he
really does something independently and
really like makes up his own mind and
really does something against the wishes
of his counselors and the one time he
does that it it is a decision that
causes tension and conflict so yeah
viserys viserys really [ __ ] up uh
plumsify in the live chat says is this
all Otto hightower's fault yeah well
Otto Hightower was the one who suggested
that Alice and go and comfort the king
in his bed Chambers I think it is clear
that Otto
Otto's plan is for viserys to marry
Allison and to thereby increase the
power of his house
um
so to the extent that the marriage to
Alison causes conflict it is kind of
Otto's fault yeah I mean this sort of is
a story of rivalry between house
Hightower and house valerion both
competing to be the second house in The
Realm by marrying the king
so Otto certainly is and you know Otto
we don't know much about Otto's like
backstory I guess we don't know much
about his real sort of motivations but
he does seem overwhelmingly driven by
ambition and he's willing to manipulate
in order to get what he wants whereas
callers like callus is also very
ambitious because more direct and
Corliss is more honest he's like hey I
want you to marry my daughter because it
will make the realm strong and we are a
strong house and so we should do it
Carlos is honest and straightforward
whereas
Otto is more scheming and manipulative a
bit like Littlefinger
so I think that does sort of frame him
as being more villainous for sure
um it's interesting Otto's
characterization like in the books he's
described as being haughty and imperious
and I sort of get the sense that in the
book
Otto is more direct
so I feel like that's a little bit of a
change compared to the book but yeah uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Aiden who
says why does Daenerys not use a saddle
but they do uh great question I think
that Daenerys should use a saddle it was
very silly in the Game of Thrones show
that Daenerys was just Clinging On to
drogon's back
um I think she would instantly fall off
but but they've made that wise change in
hot day thanks for the Super Chat from
hudsonizer who says any chance we get
some secret parentage stuff with Kristen
Cole or Allison or somebody uh I'm not
going to spoil anything but uh that may
be a relevant idea Musa says is mazaria
from ye T so yeah we got some scenes
from messaria played by sonoya Mizuno
and mazaria is daemon's lover and she
and he found her in a brothel in lace
which is one of these Eastern cities
lease is renowned for its brothels
because of course it is because this was
written by George Martin
um
so they are lovers and mazaria in the
books is described as a very pale older
woman
um she like probably in the books looks
lacine lacini I guess uh who generally
look like valerians and targaryens
they're usually like white and blonde
and often with purple eyes in the books
um whereas Missouri is played by Sonora
Mizuno maybe she's from UT in the show I
don't know Yeti is like a sort of
Imperial China in the Game of Thrones
books
um but yeah they don't really specify
like what she looks like Beyond being
pale and older
um and you know mazari explains her
background in this episode she says that
she's been sold more times than she can
count and she it sounds like she's she's
got a history of being exploited and
enslaved it's sort of a similar
background to Melisandre actually
Melisandre in the books uh was
originally a slave called Melanie in a
shy it seems um and she was sort of
traumatized and toughened up by her
horrible experiences
um and that sort of led her to adopt
such like a Hardline philosophy as a
fanatic of relore and all of that so I I
think there's this idea of sort of
strength deriving from trauma
um which you may or may not enjoy as an
idea I gotta say I did dislike
like I thought the accent was just it
didn't sound glued to me I don't know
what accent that's meant to be just her
speaking in an accent I didn't enjoy
personally which is a shame because I
really really liked sonoya Mizuno in uh
the TV show devs and in the TV show
Maniac I really like sanoya Mizuno but
like this mazario performance it just
sounds weird to my ears maybe it's just
me
um thanks for the Super Chat from
chickenpower who says do you have any
inside information about when alt drift
X will make another Game of Thrones
Abridged there is a YouTuber called Old
schwift X which I I advise everyone to
avoid but old Swift X does a podcast
live stream series called Game of
Thrones Abridged discussing each Game of
Thrones book chapter in order and uh
it's there's no schedule there it's all
over the place it's very strange very
very very irresponsible oh shrift X
thanks to the Super Chat from sweetness
who says the framing of the shots with
Daemon and Otto was so captivating also
loved how viserys and strong got
together yeah I really enjoyed the scene
between Otto and Daemon and I really
loved how Otto was so like disempowered
when Rainier turned up
um like this was a confrontation between
Damon and Otto
Otto was trying to get the dragon egg
back trying to end daemon's Rebellion
again against the king but then rhaenyra
swoops in with a dragon and suddenly
like otters just standing there like it
did in the wind like he's got he's once
the dragons turn up everyone who doesn't
have a dragon is irrelevant you know and
I think that's part of why there's this
idea of a maester conspiracy against
dragons and potentially a maester
Hightower conspiracy against dragons
because
the dragons make everyone who doesn't
have a dragon weak and irrelevant and I
think you can see on Otto's face how
much he hates that
um
and you know maybe it's like if you
can't beat them join them type thing
like if you can't beat the dragon Lords
marry into the family of the dragonlords
you know so yeah I enjoyed this
confrontation I enjoyed daemon's
performance and I really enjoyed that
you know Daemon like we find out like
Daemon declared to everybody that like
hey I'm gonna marry mazaria and mazaria
is pregnant with my child and we see in
this moment
you look on mazaria's face she didn't
know that she and Daemon are supposedly
getting married and also mazaria isn't
pregnant Daemon said she was but she
isn't Missouri said that she can't get
pregnant so
I really thought that was
interesting that Daemon just makes up
these crazy lies and it's all just a
plea for attention like they've sort of
said that in interviews and
um you know
Otto said it here as well basically he's
like are you so desperate for viserys's
attention that you'll just do this crazy
[ __ ] stealing dragon eggs taking over
this island and I think that's what
they're going for in the show like
Daemon is really just sort of acting out
to try and get acknowledgment and
attention from viserys and then we had
this confrontation between Rainier and
Daemon and she sort of tells him like
Hey like you're sitting in my seat
because the Dragonstone is a symbol of
the heir to the throne like
traditionally the air to the throne is
the prince of Dragonstone and by taking
it over Daemon is sort of taking
rhaenyra's place when she's meant to be
the heir and so rhaenyra sort of says
like hey you know I'm I'm the problem
for you I am the obstacle between you
and the throne Daemon so why don't you
just kill me if you killed me then you
would be the heir to the throne
um and I thought it was a bit silly like
it's a bit cliche like she says to
Daemon kill me just do it which is such
a cliched line that's in a lot of things
but I did enjoy daemon's reaction when
like he sort of stares down rhaenyra and
it looks like oh [ __ ] like he really is
thinking about killing Reign hero like
he he really is thinking if I killed
Rainier I would be the heir to the
throne I could I could seize power but
he decides not to do it and I think he
he doesn't do it for several reasons
um like one there clearly is some
affection and some understanding and
some connection between Daemon and
Rainier
um and also I think Daemon knows that if
he killed rhaenyra viserys would
obviously hate him forever
so Daemon doesn't do it so so there is
this underlying loyalty where you know
people think that Damon is power hungry
and and he is but he cares about his
family more despite all the ways that
Daemon works against his family He does
care about rangiora and about viserys
thanks for the donation from prietro who
says Melos also tells Otto about the
status of Emma's childbirth before he
tells viserys yeah
Otto is the one that then conveys it to
viserys but it's interesting that Melos
first goes to Otto yeah last episode
Melos told Otto about Emma first and if
you want to get really uh paranoid you
could say that well what if the maesters
deliberately somehow caused Emma's
childbirth to go wrong maybe that
C-section wasn't even necessary but they
wanted to kill Emma so that
um viserys was single so that viserys
could marry Alison like if you want to
get old conspiratorial you can
um I also thought like in this episode
it was cool how you know viserys said
I'm gonna go and confront Daemon on
Dragonstone but then Otto replied no
your grace I cannot allow it like Otto
overruled the king and said no King
viserys you're not going to go to
Dragonstone I'm gonna go to Dragonstone
so it's like who's in charge here you
know like so often it seems like Otto is
in charge not king viserys
um and of course you know Otto going
himself to Dragonstone not viserys not
anyone else gives Otto control of the
situation maybe Otto would choose to
kill Daemon you know if he could like if
Otto turned this into an attack on
Dragonstone killing daemon's gold cloaks
maybe Otto could see this as an
opportunity to get demon out of the way
once and for all you know but that plan
was ruined by Rainier Rainier turning up
so you know Auto although in so many
ways is the one who's really in charge I
think uh Dan in the Super Chat says
what's the backstory on Auto becoming
hand
Otto became hand of the king to King
jahiris the previous king
um and he sort of took over from Joe
Harris when Joe Harris was old like
Jairus ruled long and well by most
people's opinions
um but his favorite like best friend and
hand septon bath died and Jay Harris's
wife alisane died and his sons died and
so towards the end of his Reign Harris
was just like an empty shell of a man
like he was just really sad he was old
he was weak he was starting to lose his
marbles
um and so that's when Otto Hightower
came in and sort of took over on
joharis's behalf and so Otto just sort
of continued to be hand into the reign
of King viserys and interestingly like
Alison also had a role in this Alison in
the books looked after King jahiris in
his final years almost like a nurse or
something
and in the book mushroom the jester
claims that Alison performed sexual
favors for Joe Harris towards the end of
his life which is interesting there is
an age difference between elephant and
rhaenyra in the books Alison is like 10
years older
so in the book when viserys declares
he's going to marry Alison Rainier is
actually cool with it in the book
because Alison and rhaenyra are not best
friends in the book as far as we know
um and so it's not like a super weird
thing like she's cool with it but here
they've made it a lot more dramatic by
making this sort of like surprise
betrayal thanks for the Super Chat from
k-pro who says great episode love your
thoughts loved viserys talking to Alison
about alt valyria yeah this was
unexpected this was this was fun so
viserys has this little model this
little train set of old valyria and
apparently he's basing it on like
historical records viserys is a real
history nerd viserys should have been a
bloody maester not a king he's just
unsuited to being King but anyway we get
a little bit of law about valyria which
I was not expecting this is you know a
little bit of mildly new information and
I think it came directly from George
Martin because I've heard George Martin
talk about similar stuff in interviews
um House history of Westeros history of
Westeros is the name of a really good
YouTube channel and podcast that talks
about A Song of Ice and Fire Aziz and
ashaya they've been doing it for a long
time they are they are some of the
original Game of Thrones fan expert
Community Creator people and you should
all check them out because history of
Westeros did an interview with George
Martin recently where he talked about
some of this Valeria stuff so they say
that the capital of valyria was was
based it was located on a volcano in the
books they talk about the 14 Flames
which are these this mountain range of
Highly volcanic
um volcanoes and in the books there were
all these slaves who work in the mines
under the volcanoes and it's like this
burning hot hellish underworld where
valyria keeps on conquering all these
places and sending all these slaves back
to their minds under the 14 Flames to
mine for gold and there's all these
monsters under the volcanoes and it's
all terrifying
um and there's this idea of the Valyrian
blood Mages who do these sorceries and
in the books it's not super clear what
these Valyrian blood Mages do exactly
and like how it relates to the fires of
the volcano but like here in the show
they're sort of speaking as though the
14 Flames are the source of their magic
and power which is an interesting idea
which isn't really in the books but the
volcanoes as the actual source of
Valyrian magic the books say that all
Valyrian magic is rooted in Fire and
Blood
um so their connections with the dragons
but one of the other things that the
books talk about is some really mess
stop like genetic experiments that the
Valyrian blood Mages do
um quote the valyrians
um hold on quote the valyrians were more
than dragonlords they practiced blood
magic
they practiced blood magic and other
dark arts as well delving into the Earth
for Secrets best left buried and
twisting the Flesh of beasts and men to
Fashion monstrous and unnatural chimeras
and for these sins the Gods in their
wrath struck them down so you know when
we're talking blood magic we're not
talking Expelliarmus and alohomoro we're
talking about like making Frankenstein's
monsters like the island of Dr Moreau
we're talking about like torturous
horrific things and creatures that
should not exist
um quote in the flesh pits of gorgosos
the flesh pits of gogosos blood sorcery
of the darkest sort was practiced as
beasts were mated to slave women to
bring forth Twisted half human children
that's something that Valyrian blood
Mages did in the island of gogosos off
satorios in the Basilisk Isles
um
so again like the valyrians and like
maybe like not not good
the valerians are horrible that they are
conquerors who enslave thousands and
kill a lot of people and do [ __ ] up
magic experiments to create chimeras and
you know you can speculate that maybe
this Valyrian blood magic hybridizing
animals maybe that's where dragons come
from maybe valerians took wyverns who
were these big lizards
um and through blood magic created
dragons and maybe uh dragons and
targaryens like maybe the targaryens
were created by combining the genetics
of dragons and humans and that's why
dragons and targaryens have a special
bond
um there's all sorts of like dark messed
up stuff there uh and you know that's
who viserys is idolizing and um you know
I they also talk hold on that was
and this was the anagram I don't know
what the anagram is that there's no
mention of an enogrion it's where the
blood Mages worked their crops so I
guess the enogrion is a place in the
city of valyria where the blood Mages
worked
um that's never been mentioned before
that's new and I wonder if some of this
World building comes from the
development of the Doom of valyria TV
show
there was a leak an alleged leak years
ago that apparently was a bunch of
information from a TV show that HBO was
working on about the Doom of valyria and
about valyria before the Doom so I guess
some of this law might have been created
for that and I guess that maybe George
Martin was involved in creating it I
don't know but um yeah really
interesting but part of the Valeria
stuff is that you know when you talk
about valyria you're talking about the
downfall of a great Empire and that's
what viserys says like are you talking
about the height or it's fall and so I
think that talking about valyria it sort
of puts the modern day House Targaryen
in the context of downfall in the
context of Doom in the context of
decline because just like valyria House
Targaryen is currently at their peak of
power and when you're at the peak
there's a long way to fall down so I
think that that's part of why they're
talking about valyria is to get us
thinking about downfall the
inevitability of Decline and that sort
of contrasts with the sum Knights stuff
that they were they were talking about
last episode
um so yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from Brinks
who says one difference I like is how
they aged down Allison so it makes it
more spicy when yeah I agree
thanks for the Super Chat from Brennan
who says they weren't subtle with all
the meaningful looks between Otto and
Melos yeah I agree
um but the Lord strong and viserys
conversation surprised me yeah that that
was interesting giving Lionel a bit of
one-on-one time with the king
um and it'll be interesting to see where
that leads thanks for the Super Chat
from Kuro who says can you talk more
about daemon's wife yeah uh oh you're
talking about mazaria yeah well we
already talked about her she's from
lease she was a sex worker or a dancer
possibly and we don't know much
specifics about her in the books other
than other than that she's an older
woman she's very pale and she is a close
Confidant of Daemon thanks for the
donation from Gotham Knight who says
that awkward moment when your best
friend becomes your stepmom yep also
love the imagery of maggots feeding off
his hand yeah yeah and yeah and Gotham
says the maggots feeding off his hand as
his subject's feed off his wife and sons
corpses yeah it's a great point I mean
that's like viserys's line in the
previous episode where he says you know
I don't want I don't want you feasting
on my dead son and wife like like crows
on their corpses it's perverse that you
know viserys is mourning the deaths of
his family this horrible trauma but all
these politicians around him are trying
to get him to hook up with hook up with
children to create new you know hairs
and things and that's what's interesting
fundamentally about all of these stories
I think is the merging of the personal
with the political
I think that's why royal families are
such great fodder for drama because they
combine power and huge stakes and
kingdoms and battles with the intimate
like you know relationships and sexual
details and and all of that intimate
human stuff
um I think that's why who have been
making stories about Kings since
Shakespeare and Gilgamesh it's the
personal and the political but yeah like
it was really interesting to see that
viserys's hand uh is is
rotting viserys's finger seems to be
infected and that seems to be that's the
exact cut that viserys got on his hand
last episode after he dismissed Daemon
he cut his finger on the sharp Iron
Throne which has all this symbolism
about its you know power is killing him
power is cutting him the throne is is
hurting him rejecting him as though he's
not a good King he's not handling power
well and so power is hurting him and
this finger is getting worse so it's
like it's like he's falling apart he's
disintegrating in the face of power and
kingship
um
if you want to get really conspiratorial
you might wonder if the maesters are
actually helping viserys heal or if the
maesters are deliberately making it
worse oh who knows
um but yeah that's obviously a very bad
sign something is rotten in the state of
Denmark when the king is rotting I love
it uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Martian who says will we learn more
about valyria in the show
um yeah I mean it we we are learning
more this episode and yeah you're right
that Valeria is similar to Dragonstone
um in that Dragonstone is built on a
volcano and you know there is this idea
that dragons like the Heat and that's
why they put uh the dragon egg when
rhaenyra got the dragon egg back they
immediately put the dragon egg in this
Brazier here full of hot coals so like
they like to keep the dragon eggs hot
because it seems that the dragon eggs
only tend to hatch when they're kept hot
so I guess that's why you know
Dragonstone is on a is on a volcano and
the City of valyria it was on these
volcanoes I guess you need volcanic heat
to make dragons hatch and that's not
true all of the time sometimes dragon
eggs hatch elsewhere like daenerys's
dragons
but that is a general principle yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from game Who
Says were there any Stark Lannister
Baratheon Tully or other noble families
viserys could marry I doubt those were
his only choices yeah they're absolutely
are lots of other powerful families who
he potentially could have made a match
with I mean you know so far at least in
the books the targaryens have
mostly married uh valerions at least
like the Royal Line has and they've made
a change to that in the show here
um because like the way that viserys and
Corliss are talking
um it makes it clear that the targaryens
and the valerions haven't married before
whereas in the books the targaryens and
valerians have married a lot so like J
Harris's mother was a valerion aegon's
mother was a valerion it sounds like in
the show they've changed it so that like
this marriage between uh viserys and
Lena that's proposed that would be the
first marriage
um and I guess that makes sense given
that in the show the targaryens and the
valerions look different with the
valerions being black
um that's a change from the books and I
guess it makes more sense in the show
Canon they look different because
they've never married each other in the
show I mean it begs the question of like
who the valerians are marrying because
in order to like still look different to
most of the other houses like like they
must be even more incestuous than the
type carrions are you know like other
valerians mostly marrying other
valerians I don't know but um yeah I
think that that sort of reconciles with
the book Canon a bit more
um
but yeah like I would think that viserys
totally could have married into other
houses it seems like sort of uh
impulsive personal decision to marry
Alison
um it seems like he was you know he just
likes talking to her she listens and she
gave him a little Dragon toy and I guess
that's all he needs in a partner
um he maybe he's sort of projecting some
of his affection and his feelings for
his dead wife Emma onto Allison because
like you know in Alison and viserys's
conversations like she isn't saying a
whole lot like she's mostly just being
polite and listening like
and it's sort of uncomfortable how like
you know viserys uses Alison as a way to
connect with his daughter rhaenyra
because Alice and Israel's friend and
you know he asks Alison not to tell
Rainier about their conversations and
about their relationship or their
friendship or whatever the hell it is so
that obviously puts Alison in like a
really difficult on the situation where
it's like well she has to obey her King
but she also has a loyalty to her friend
rhaenyra you know so like you know even
in these scenes later in the sept it's
like you know Alison is being a good
friend to Rainier but she's also
withholding this information about her
relationship with the King and it sort
of like you know does Alison like
Allison must know that her father Otto
wants her to marry king viserys
um but Alison isn't telling rhaenyra
that and that that's sort of messed up
in the inside the episode feature after
the episode they said that um Alison's
actress said that Alison is just being
with viserys out of kindness like she's
not manipulating him and trying to court
him but like
Otto is and surely Alison knows that so
yeah and then you know we had this
really uncomfortable dinner scene with
viserys and rhaenyra and I loved how you
could visit he could hear you could hear
crickets in the background which
highlighted the silence the
uncomfortable silence between rainyro
and viserys and they just sort of failed
to communicate and to connect like
they're both trying but they're not
doing a great job
um and you know at the council room
viserys sort of interrupted rhaenyra and
talked over her and like he obviously
like cares about it like he's angry that
she went to Dragonstone without his
permission and his anger I think comes
from a place of love like I think he's
trying to be protective of his daughter
um especially after the traumatic death
of his wife you know like he wants to
protect rhaenyra from slipping out of
his hands like like Emma did so you know
I think it's at least partly coming from
a good place a place of love but he is
sort of overriding Rainier's
Independence and treating her like a
child when he should be treating her
like the heir to the throne if he's
serious serious about making of the head
of the throne he should be
allowing her to make some independent
decisions and to be more than just a cup
Bearer and rhaenyra is very frustrated
by being treated as just a little girl
when she's meant to be the heir to the
throne so and I think it's really
interesting comparing that to Otto and
um Otto and Allison's relationship
because Otto also is kind of harsh with
Alison like he tells her oh you're the
most beautiful woman why are you biting
your fingers why are you destroying
yourself and it sort of comes across as
a bit harsh with Otto and Allison but
like you know that also is coming at
least partly from a place of concern and
love like he doesn't want his daughter
to hurt herself but like the way he
expresses that comes across as a bit
harsh and cold and aggressive and you
know the difference between Otto and
viserys is that while viserys is sort of
honestly and respectfully saying like
hey rhaenyra I believe in you you I want
you to be the ruler because you're great
and I regret that this puts you in a
hard position but like I respect that
you can do this that's what he said last
episode whereas Otto is sort of pushing
Alison into like a you know go and Bone
the king please but he's not we don't
see him treating Allison with the same
sort of openness and respect that we see
viserys at least occasionally attempting
with rhaenyra so I mean you know
father-daughter relationships are I
guess a theme of this show and with Otto
and viserys and Rainier and Allison
thanks for the Super Chat from holla at
you who says was wondering if Allison's
fingernail picking was from her hating
being pimped out by her father or a
general personality trait yeah so
Allison keeps on picking at her fingers
and her cuticles and and sort of like
nail biting which I think is a really
great way to show how Alison is feeling
um despite her words
um because
because like obviously when you're
reading the novels The Game of Thrones
novels you get to read the characters
thoughts and when you adapt that to the
screen it's much more difficult because
you can't you don't have inner monologue
being audible unless it's um unless
you're watching the David Lynch June
movie
um so you know there are there are a few
moments in this episode when Alison
is smiling and like saying polite things
but under the surface she's like picking
at her fingers that was a there was a
moment when she was doing that yeah yeah
so look at this like she's smiling she's
looking like she's all good and having a
good time and being nice but but under
the table she's picking at her fingers
so you know she's appearing like she's
cool with everything but deep down she's
actually really uncomfortable with
everything and you see the same thing
she's picking at her fingers when she is
declared to be the king's betrothed so
it's an act like Alison is sort of
trying to behave like the way that she's
been taught to behave but really she's
desperately uncomfortable with
everything that's going on
um so yeah I think that's a really
significant tell when she's picking at
her fingers like that thanks for the
Super Chat from Titan who says besides
writing couldn't he marry both girls you
talking about viserys I mean like yeah I
mean there is a history of Targaryen
polygamy
um King aegon the first the Conqueror
married his sisters rhaenys and visenya
maegor Targaryen married no fewer than
six women and didn't didn't manage to
Father a surviving child on any of them
um but there's a bit of a uh issue with
the faith of the seven the the religion
of Westeros considers polygamy and
incest to be sins and so that's why the
targaryens stopped marrying multiple
women
um and have sort of eased off on the
incest occasionally is to try and
placate the faith and I thought it was
really interesting in this scene that
like Alison was sort of teaching
rhaenyra how to pray
it seems as though Allison is very
familiar with the faith of the seven
which makes sense because she's a high
tower and the faith of the seven is
based in Old Town which is the high
Tower City uh but Rainier it seems as
though she she doesn't have much
experience in septs and praying so
Alison sort of teaches her how because
you know the targaryens come from
valyria they don't have the same history
with the faith of the servant they often
do pay lip service to the seven like
they often you know they they need to be
friends with the faith because the faith
is powerful
but the targaryens are generally not as
devout as some others are
um thanks for the Super Chat from pistol
who says one out of ten how Petty was
the dragon egg throw yeah I thought that
was quite funny how Daemon just sort of
he has this confrontation he sort of
considers killing rhaenyra but then he's
just like ah nah [ __ ] it and he just
like throws the dragon egg to Rainier
um and I thought I thought it was quite
funny how abruptly Daemon just dropped
everything and left after this big
confrontation and he's like all right
fine and just gives up and and walks
home and then starts his own party with
with Corliss
um I thought that was that was fun I
thought I think Daemon Matt Smith's
performance throughout has been fun
thanks for the Super Chat from sudarsan
who says in the show Daenerys was born
in 281ac and the Mad King was dead into
80 AC but the pilot episode showed 172
years before both events uh how's the
dragon is Canon more with the books than
Game of Thrones look I don't think that
the original Game of Thrones show or
this house of the dragon show are too
precise with timelines and years because
like mostly because like the actors
don't age in line with the show timeline
they age in according to to the real
timeline um I wouldn't worry too much
about the specifics of years because I
don't think any of the shows are going
to get it perfectly right
um even George [ __ ] up the years
sometimes in his books he's very
deliberate to sort of avoid using
specific years in the main as long as
and Fire books
um I wouldn't worry too much about the
timeline I I like they're already like
changing things a lot in the TV show
they're mostly compressing the timeline
so that like the stuff all happens close
together so they don't have to say and
then in the next year and then like
every scene doesn't happen a year later
like that they are compressing the
timeline in the show thanks for the
Super Chat from captrick who says the
smug look Otto had on his face when
viserys announced who he was marrying
was great yeah he was pretty pleased
with himself that is what he wanted all
along and he got it
uh call us his face less happy
um so yeah that was fun thanks for the
Super Chat from Zach who said who did
convince viserys to marry Allison it
felt so out of the blue to announce that
yeah I think that we are meant to see
this as a somewhat impulsive emotional
personal decision I mean you know we saw
him sitting at his desk with the dragon
statue
um which Alison gave him so I think he
sort of sees that as like oh she you
know has some insight into my interests
and feelings and needs and you know I
think viserys is lonely and like you
know who is viserys's friend like like
who does viserys have to talk to he he
doesn't like he doesn't have a great
relationship with Rainier
um and all of his counselors are
politicians who he knows you know want
him for political reasons so it's like I
think viserys is lonely and he wants
someone to talk to and Allison is that
um I think that the xeris is not very
empathic to Alison's needs because
viserys doesn't seem to notice Allison's
discomfort with her picking at her
fingernails and stuff
um but you know some people just want a
partner who is someone who will listen
and smile and give you dragons I guess
and uh that is what viscera sees in
Alison so um you know I I guess you know
viserys is also very aware that he
mostly just does what people tell him to
do and after all these times of just
going along with what everyone else
wants he's like no [ __ ] it like I'm
gonna do what I want for once and that's
why he chooses Alison
but of course Otto's manipulations
unlike that thanks for the Super Chat
from Kate and from Taylor who says in
the last episode did anyone catch
viserys elude that the Doom of Illyria
is the dragon's fault are they trying to
canonize the Doom yeah so they did talk
about the Doom uh of valyria last
episode and yeah viserys talked as
though the Doom was caused by the
dragons which is it doesn't say that in
the books like in the books it says that
no one knows what caused the Doom of
valyria
um it may have been a natural occurrence
like a volcanic a cataclysmic volcanic
super eruption of the 14 Flames it may
have been related to the blood Mages who
performed Magic on the 14 Flames like it
seems as though the Valyrian Sorcerers
did Magic to prevent the 14 Flames from
erupting but like there were too few
Mages some people speculate that like
the Faceless Men killed some of the
Mages and that caused their corruption
because the Faceless Men the The Guild
of Assassins that Arya joins they they
come from the slaves of valyria and
braavos comes from escaped slaves of
valyria
um so there are all these different
theories about what caused the Doom I
mean symbolically it's about that their
pride and their power and their evil led
to their downfall as a sort of Justice
you know the gods punishing the
valyrians for their arrogance but yeah
in the books the eruption is a mystery
whereas the show ties it more directly
to the dragons thanks to the Super Chat
from Anthony who says is the we are
second Sons line from Corliss a
foreshadowing to the second son's
mercenaries later on so yeah like in the
books Tyrion joins a sell sword
mercenary company called the second Sons
um and the and and callus like Compares
him and viserys to Second sons in this
which which I liked I thought it was
cool how Corliss and viserys both see
themselves as people who you know they
they don't inherit
um Power they have to make power and I
mean call us did inherit being Lord of
Lord of driftmark but but call us in the
books he is a great adventurer who did
these great voyages across the world and
he made his house the richest in the
world by or the richest in Westeros by
doing all this trade and all this
adventuring and exploring
and Daemon similarly like he only gets
what he
um works for in the sense that you know
they're not going to put him on the
throne so he's got to make his own power
he's going to make his own moves
um so yeah I like that parallel and yeah
it's interesting that it connects to
that mercenary company
um thanks for the Super Chat from KB who
says how do you feel about the pacing
yeah I think the pacing works I mean
like this story happens over years so
like they need to do the time jumps
um I think they are setting the
necessary groundwork so far at least
um thanks for the Super Chat from
Danielle who says does the mask of
crackers crab feeder have anything to do
with the harpy masks in Game of Thrones
the answer is no um I guess it is a
similar design like I remember the sons
of the harpy uh in Game of Thrones
season five and six these guys that's
the sons of the harpy and Marine
um I agree it is sort of a similar
design to crack ass crab feeder's mask
isn't it but um yeah that that mask yeah
that does look kind of similar doesn't
it
maybe it's a reused prop or something
but uh but no I don't think it's
connected
thanks for the Super Chat from Joseph
who says wait you overlooked the fact
that if Daemon killed rhaenyra her
Dragon would instantly kill him in
return I mean possibly but you know uh
Daemon also has his dragon karaxi's as
backup but yeah I mean that's a good
point I mean I mean what rhaenyra says
is that you know Rainier is intervention
rhaenyra turning up here with Cyrax
prevented violence because like if she
wasn't there then Otto might have
attacked and then curraxis would have
burned the [ __ ] out of everyone and a
bunch of people might have died
um but rhaenyra bringing Cyrax is a sort
of a nuclear deterrent it means that
well if there's violence we could all
die you know like yeah if Daemon killed
rhaenyra I guess Cyrax would kill Daemon
yeah and then karaxi's would kill
everyone so dragons sometimes escalate
violence but also can prevent it I think
we're gonna see a bit of that as the
story continues thanks for the Super
Chat from wandering kangaroo who says
what was Otto's plan with Dragonstone
did he forget that demon on had a bloody
dragon
yeah that's a good point like what what
exactly was Otto thinking was gonna
happen here
um I mean maybe Otto's plan was like a
Siege like maybe Otto could just block
any ships from getting onto Dragon
Stones just to like starve out Daemon
and his gold cloaks because yeah like if
he tries to attack Daemon and daemon's
dragon with just a bunch of foot
soldiers he's gonna have a bad time and
you know Daemon himself is a deadly
Warrior so it's um yeah I'm not sure
exactly what Otto's plan was I mean
maybe he was secretly sending some
soldiers around the back of the castle
to capture mazaria or grab hostages or
crossbowmen to shoot Daemon like yeah it
might have been cool if we actually got
to see Otto being devious and having a
plan and you know like like in Game of
Thrones season seven and eight uh you
know there were those scorpion
ballisters that shoot those giant
um those giant bolts that can hurt
dragons so like you know there are
things you can do to try and kill
dragons and uh yeah it may have made
sense if Otto did some of those things
thanks for the Super Chat from Max who
says is Melisandre around during this
time because she old yeah Melisandre is
old and I think it is possible that
Melisandre is alive
um in the show carice Van Houten the
actress said that Melisandre is hundreds
of years old and this is like 170 years
or
190 years
um before Game of Thrones so yeah
Melisandre might be alive right now
somewhere in uh or essos or something I
don't think she's likely to make a cameo
but I it's not impossible I suppose
thanks for the Super Chat from Jones
City who says do you think they will
take creative Liberties that make sense
perhaps describing Corliss valerion's
mother as having summer Islander
ancestry yeah so like that was one
possibility
um like with the valerions being black
and looking different to the targaryens
um one possibility that people were
speculating on is that maybe the
valerians in the show intermarried with
the summer Islanders and the summer
islands of this area to the south of
Westeros where the people have dark skin
and that kind of like made sense in the
sense that like both the valerians and
the summer Islanders are known for
sailing and being Explorers so like it
kind of makes a lot of sense that the
valerians might have some kind of
Interest or alliance with the summer
Islanders maybe they didn't to marry and
that would be a way of resolving
that like the valerions had intermarried
with the targaryens in the past and they
look similar but then more recently the
valerians had intermarried with the
summer Islanders like yeah I think that
would hypothetically make sense but I
think in this episode they're revealing
that no in the show the valerians
haven't intermarried with the targaryens
before so I think what they're going for
is that the valerians have always been
black in the TV show Canon
um like all the way back to Old valyria
which I think also like makes sense
because Valeria was a giant Empire that
covered like a whole continent they
there are going to be multiple like
there are multiple ethnicities under the
Yoke of valyria and involved in valyria
um and maybe you know some of the
Highborn families of valyria you know
they're probably intermarian whatever
but some of them practice incest like
the targaryens particularly the Dragon
Riders practiced incest and so it makes
sense that they may have a different
appearance to the people who they aren't
into marrying with you know so you know
I think it makes sense to me that
there's multiple ethnicities in valyria
um and the valyrians you know the
valerions are explicitly one of the less
powerful houses they're sort of separate
from the Dragon Riders
um and uh call us talks about them sort
of being underdogs who had to make their
way by like the sea and stuff so I think
there's plenty of room in the law for
black valerions in hot day
thanks for the Super Chat from
johanathan and Devin and eternal
Blockbuster who says love the convo
between rhaenyra and rhaenys yeah that
was cool to see
that was cool to see because basically
what that was was rhaenyra was watching
her father viserys caught this 12 year
old Lena valerion and that's a threat to
rhaenyra because rhaenyra is supposed to
be the heir to the throne but if viserys
has a child with Lana that could
potentially probably replace rhaenyra
especially if viserys and Lena have a
son
um Rainier is supposedly the air but
that can change especially if you know
there's a son because Lords prefer male
rulers and so that's what rhaenys tells
rhaenyra she's like hey like this has
all happened before this happened to me
I was you know potentially going to be
the out of the throne but I was replaced
by Balon and then by viserys and so the
Lords of Westeros have made it very
clear that they don't want women on the
throne and you know I get a sense of
almost a bit of jealousy from rainey's
almost as though rhaenys is like you
know I didn't succeed I didn't get to be
ruler so therefore I don't want you to
be ruler either you know like I get it's
I get a slight sense of spite from Frank
nice but at the same time she's being a
sort of a mentor and being a sort of
honest like she's the one person who's
being honest to Rainier and telling her
hey don't you see what's happening don't
you see you're being bullshitted people
are telling you that you're Heir but
they're not treating you like air
they're treating you like a cup error
they're treating you like a little girl
and that is Rainier's frustration in
this episode
and so you know rainey's delivers this
line the the Lords of Westeros would
rather put the realm to the torch than
see a woman
um come to the Iron Throne so that's one
of the key themes of this series is is
patriarchy and sexism and people
preferring male rulers
um and rhaenyra wants to reject that
rhaenyra says in this scene I will make
a new order when I become Queen so
rhaenyra is like a revolutionary she
wants to change she's Progressive she
wants to change the system make the
system more fair
um and it's going to be really
interesting to see if she can stick to
those ideals with the story going
forward like will Rainier succeed
um because there's always the pushback
from politics and political realities
and
um yeah so it's going to be very
interesting and and you know there's
also this idea of you know one of the
tragedies of the patriarchy is that it
turns women against each other
um Sometimes women have internalized
misogyny and women have internalized
patriarchal rules and sometimes
women hurt each other instead of helping
each other under male domination so yeah
I think these are all ideas that are
going to be played with more and more
going ahead thanks for the Super Chat
from Isaiah who says something spoilery
thanks to the Super Chat from Jay Burch
who says Hey shift do you think lady
Ellison is playing the game of thrones
with viserys or is this a situation she
can't get out of
I think that Alison thinks that she
needs to obey Otto and viserys like I
think that you know Alison like Sansa is
just trying to be what she's been told
she must be all her life she's trying to
be a obedient Noble lady being polite
being kind and doing what the men say
um and I think that like Sansa she may
increasingly realize that uh that sucks
in contrast to rhaenyra who has already
decided that that sucks so you know I
think it's I think Allison is clearly
not like a big schemer herself like I
don't think Alison is going haha this
dumbass viserys is falling for my Wiles
like they said in the inside the episode
she's like no Allison is just trying to
be kind she's just trying to be
courteous
um so I don't think elephant is a
plotter but you know we will see how
that evolves uh thanks for the Super
Chat from wealthwolf who says magor's
teats and from Dopey Dragon who says
valerians equals Q so that's a reference
to all tomorrows the science fiction
short story by cm cozum in which there
is an alien race that horrifically
alters uh humans by genetic engineering
just like the valyrians do so yeah look
hey maybe George Martin and CM kozerman
are the same person have you ever seen
them in the same room uh thanks for the
Super Chat from pagay Quinn who says the
setup of Cyrax vs karaxi's was great
yeah wasn't it
I I really really enjoyed how Cyrax like
swam up through the fog like there was
like this Ripple in the fog and it was
almost like the dragon was a shark that
was like swimming up and then breaching
the surface and then Rising above all
the people I I think it's really cool
it's so much more creative than how they
did it in the original Game of Thrones
show like in the original Game of
Thrones show all the dragons looked the
same they all had the same personality
they all sounded the same and they all
mostly sort of moved the same and flew
the same and whereas here like I love
that karaxi's has a unique sound I love
that they have Saddles I love that they
have different looks and just the
visuals of swimming up from the fog I
thought was extremely cool uh thanks for
the Super Chat from Fred who said did
you see that your video about all
tomorrows made it onto bar stool Sports
I I did not see that I might check that
out thanks for the Super Chat from comfy
who says they're making the Doom of
valyria
Ambiguously because of a volcanic
eruption could the curse of valyria just
be the toxic air
so valyria is now a cursed and Demon
haunted ruin after it blew up uh it's
it's a bad place now you don't want to
be there in Game of Thrones season five
uh Jorah and Tyrion just like went to
valyria which is uh weird
because in the in the books you do not
you do not One does not simply sail into
valyria in the books no one who goes to
valyria survives except maybe for you
wrong Greyjoy but he might be full of
[ __ ] in the show they go to valyria but
that's no no no no not in the books
because in the books valyria is a
horrifying post-apocalyptic nightmare
realm uh or at least you know apparently
it is no one really knows um but there
is a bit in Fire and Blood uh set years
and years before House of the Dragon
there's a bit where a young Targaryen
princess flies to valyria apparently on
balerion like she she tried to ride
balerion but she wasn't quite in control
of balerion and valerion flew home
valerion flew back to valyria where he
came from because valerion was the
oldest dragon and
um when this Targaryen princess Aria
returned from the from valyria uh she
was very unwell she was sick and she was
hot to the touch and very messed up
and
something was inside her area's body was
like squirming with these like worms or
snakes that were inside her body and
there was smoke pouring from areas
orifices and her skin was burning up and
then these like snakes these worms with
human faces emerge from area targaryen's
body and she died and it was just this
horrifying bizarre lovecraftian spooky
event where where this septum bath was
like oh my God like these
there are some bad things in valyria and
clearly these worm humans are the result
of Valyrian blood magic hybridization
experiments and we should never never
never never go to valyria
um so I guess my point is that you know
I don't think the the Doom of valyrial
was just a volcano I think it was
clearly some magic was part of it some
dark magic was part of it and some
people think the Faceless Men did it so
some people think that the targaryens
deliberately caused the Doom of valyria
to destroy every Dragon Rider that
wasn't them because the Doom of valyria
made the targaryens the only dragon
riders in the world and made them like
unquestionably powerful so maybe the
targaryens caused the Doom because like
the targaryens say that they saw the
Doom coming because of uh dany's the
dreamer had a dream about it so they
left but some people say no that's
[ __ ] that's a cover story really the
targaryens caused the Doom there's also
this stuff about like there's a there's
there was there's this prophecy about
the gold of casterly rock would be the
Doom of valyria and there's this idea
that the targaryens sold the Valyrian
steel sword bright Roar to the
Lannisters in return for Lannister gold
and that gold somehow caused the Doom
because the gold was used to hire The
Faceless Men Who Killed the Valyrian
Sorcerers that were preventing the
volcanoes from erupting and they kind of
are hints for some of these things so I
mean there is an old Triplex video about
all of this go and watch the old trip
next video about the Doom of valyria if
you're interested but my point is that
the Doom is clearly magical as well as
natural uh you know and um yeah it's uh
it's spooky [ __ ]
thanks for the Super Chat from Brent who
says when do we find out that quaith is
a character in this show uh I don't
expect to see quite but Quake is a very
mysterious person for sure
uh quaith is the masked woman who we see
in season two and um there's theories
that she might be share a sea Star the
uh girlfriend of bloodraven and there's
theories that she's uh all kinds of
people
uh thanks for the Super Chat from
upstate craze who says I'm glad the
stepstones are getting screen time the
area always interested me yeah it's
going to be really interesting to see
how they represent the stepstones we
don't know much about the stepstones uh
in the books they're just these Rocky
islands that like there's there's
nothing much important or interesting on
the islands themselves but the locations
of the islands make them a really good
staging ground to [ __ ] with people's
shipping lanes as callus is finding out
thanks for the Super Chat from yeah boy
who says just joined the stream uh but
viserys told Corliss I am your king and
in the Game of Thrones show Tywin said
any man who says I am the king is no
true king yeah that's happened several
times like viserys has said I am the
king several other characters have told
viserys you are the king and and yeah
like viserys people keep saying that
because viserys doesn't act very much
like a king viserys does not command
respect people don't always listen to
viserys like in the opening scene
everyone was back talking viserys like
Carlos was back talking vasaris Otto was
overriding viserys rhaenyra was talking
back to viserys so like he doesn't seem
like a king he doesn't act like a king
like I loved his body language all
throughout this episode like he's always
uncomfortable he's always sort of
sitting weirdly like he doesn't he and
he doesn't wear a crown most of the time
so you know and I loved his discomfort
during the Lena scene he's just like oh
God like what am I doing what look at
that expression he's just he's just not
enjoying being King and he maybe should
never have been King
which you know highlights the Injustice
that rainy did not become the ruler even
more you know like rainy seems more
qualified as a ruler than viserys does
she clearly is more focused and smart
and commanding than viserys in a lot of
ways so that sort of adds a layer of
Injustice there thanks for the super jet
from Sam who mentions a spoiler thanks
for the Super Chat from Starman who says
thoughts on Corliss and Demon at the end
yeah I uh I thought it was fun the way
they sort of slowly revealed that that
Corliss was talking to Daemon the whole
time it's like ambiguous who he's
talking to at first and I liked how they
seem to be having this conversation on
the island of driftmark which is the uh
Island where the valerians are based and
you know call us mentions like he he
built this place with his bare back
um and I think what he is referring to
there is that Corliss with the wealth
that he made from his voyages uh Corliss
built a new Castle on driftmark
um called High Tide and it's like a
newer fancier Castle than the old castle
they used to live in
colas also mentions the uh Driftwood
throne and that's the name of the seat
where the Lord valyrians valerions sit
in driftmark
um which is a little confusing calling
it a throne and it also is similar to
the Driftwood crown that the ironborn
wear but it's unrelated and I like these
sort of weird nautical themed objects
that Corliss has decorating his place
like you know this is the home of a
Ocean Explorer you know
um and I I like the characterization of
Corliss throughout the show like that
they're really using call this to
contrast against viserys and against
Otto because while viserys is sort of
trying to please everyone and he's
indecisive and he tends not to act
Corliss always wants to act he always
wants to do the thing he's always direct
he's always like let's do this whereas
Auto is really sort of subtle and
scheming and manipulative so you know
call us this Sarahs and Otto are like
these three different archetypes of
power and I think that they contrast
against each other really nicely
thanks for the Super Chat from soda who
says do you think the injury will kill
viserys uh well I'm not going to spoil
anything thanks for the Super Chat from
kazaven who says the king's hand is
festering from the wound just like is ah
just like the situation with his brother
on Dragonstone is left to Fester I agree
zedx Kevin
um yeah like like viserys is sort of
failing to act and letting the problems
continue to get worse his hand is slowly
getting worse
um maybe it would be better to like
amputate the hand you know like they're
talking about trying to save the digits
uh trying to save his finger by by
putting maggots on it and stuff but it's
like well maybe you should be more
decisive maybe you should cut it off and
maybe that would be better for your
long-term health and it's interesting
that they have this line here the wounds
made by the great Council so you know
they are already using this this
metaphor of political wounds and
emotional wounds as well as literal
physical wounds
um and yeah just like that wound that
viserys is failing to act on uh Daemon
has been sitting on Dragonstone for six
months and day one's done nothing about
it despite the the threat that that
poses to viserys's like legitimacy and
Rainier is legitimacy so
so yeah that's a good point
um and you know in the previous episode
they said that you know this is a wound
that refuses to heal so you know it's
just like you know Hamlet something is
rotten in the state of Denmark when
there is something physically rotting on
the king that says a lot about the state
of the political realm thanks for the
Super Chat from Robbie who says is it
just me or does the crab feeder have
grayscale yeah that's an interesting
thought um because yeah there obviously
is is something [ __ ] up about the crab
feeder's face like he's got a bit of a
weird skin condition going on maybe he's
just got eczema I don't know
um but my I mean my sort of headcanon I
like imagining that maybe the crab
feeder was himself nibbled by crabs at
some point and maybe that's why his face
is messed up maybe it's just a really
bad sunburn maybe he went to one of
those tanning salons maybe he uh got did
a face mask that went wrong I don't know
uh I don't imagine it's grayscale
because if it's grayscale I think
everybody else around him would also get
a great scale but I don't know I mean
that's also a cool Theory because you
know grayscale
makes you mad we saw the uh Stone man in
uh Game of Thrones season five
um they are these fellows who are sort
of uh rotting well turning into stone
from the inside and they are uh they're
not well they're not happy and um
I guess that looks vaguely similar to
crab feeder and maybe like having
grayscale could explain his craziness
because he doesn't seem like a
particularly uh sane individual and you
know I guess has a similarity there
thanks for the super jump from Taha who
says love your videos but I think this
episode was a bit Bland compared to
episode one but I keep hearing a lot of
praise for it I mean it wasn't as
eventful it wasn't as like
um uh there wasn't as much action as
there was in episode one I suppose
um there wasn't you know a death by
childbirth and a tournament and all of
that I mean they had a bit of uh
excitement with the dragon confrontation
I thought that was pretty fun I also I
also really really enjoyed this exchange
between
um Daemon and Kristen Cole so Kristen
Cole gets added to the kingsguard to
replace uh Ryan red wine R.I.P Ryan
redwine he's uh one of the most famous
and celebrated kingsguard Knights ever
or any Knights ever a this guy is Ryan
red wine
he was Lord commander of the king's God
but he died of natural causes apparently
unless he was assassinated by the high
towers and the maesters uh no he
probably wasn't
um Ryan redwine is is like super famous
and legendary although I feel like
there's sort of a bit of retconning in
the books about Ryan redwine because in
the like main original novels like bran
and several other characters are like
wow Ryan redwine he was such a cool guy
he was so amazing he did so much cool
stuff and then when George Martin got
around to writing the history book
about the time when Ryan redwine was
alive we don't actually hear stories
about Ryan redwine doing anything
particularly cool
um because like Ryan was the kingsguard
to King jaharis who ruled who was like a
peaceful ruler
um there were not a lot of like battles
or crazy incidents in the real in the
reign of King jaharis for Ryan to be
involved in and I think George Martin
kind of [ __ ] up there like I think
George Martin he said that Ryan was this
amazing dude but when he wrote the
history book he didn't have any amazing
things for Ryan to do it's just like oh
he was in some tournaments and he was
really cool so you know I don't know if
Ryan really has earned the reputation
that he has in the books but
whatever that's a side point the point
is that Ryan died and he got replaced by
Kristen Cole uh who is this hot new
kingsguard guy who defeated Daemon in
the tourney and since daemon's Pride was
wounded and since Daemon is a black belt
in [ __ ] stirring
um he he pretends to not know Kristen's
name and calls him sir Crispin just to
insult him
um which is a lot like that scene in
Game of Thrones season seven
um when Jaime Lannister uh sees dick on
tarly and he's like ah who are you again
[ __ ] sir sir rickon or something
um in season seven episode four and
dickon's like no it's dickons rickon no
no no my name's dick on
um and I think it's almost a reference
to that when Daemon in this episode says
sir Crispin what who the [ __ ] are you
so I enjoyed that and that's obviously a
rivalry that they are building up
um there's only room for one hot warrior
in this in this Kingdom Daemon seems to
think so I think we can expect a fun
rivalry between Kristen and Daemon to
continue thanks for the Super Chat from
Jack roffes who says which bits are you
excited to see I I'm not spoiling
anything in this live stream so we won't
spoil future events thanks for the Super
Chat from Antoine who says the key to a
perfect marriage be polite and listen
yeah well you've also got to speak in a
relationship
it can't be a one-way thing if if one
person does all the talking and one
person does all the listening uh I I you
can't have a proper relationship because
you can't uh learn each other's needs
and attend to them so I think that the
viserys Ellison relationship it's a bit
asymmetrical and of course you know it's
a relationship between a king and a
teenager so of course it's asymmetrical
you know like there's a lot of talk
these days about you know sexual
relationships needing to be on more
equal footing in terms of power
um and that's not possible in this
particular uh fictional monarchical
Medieval World because you know people
explicitly have more power than others
along lines of you know Kings and Lords
and status and in terms of gender and
all sorts of stuff so
you know it's interesting trying to
apply I guess you know like modern
gender ideas to
um a medieval fantasy because you know
there's there's some loud people on the
internet who will say that you know we
don't want any modern politics in our
fictional dragon show and you know there
may be you know that that may be
reasonable to a point but also like you
know George Martin is a modern
um contemporary person writing in a
contemporary World
um the point of art the point of fantasy
is to comment on current feelings and
experiences it doesn't have to be you
know about the politics of 2022 but it
has to be relevant to our lives now so I
don't know I guess it's an open question
you know to what extent this show is
about current contemporary issues and
feelings and how much it is about a
fictional imaginary realm because you
know people appreciate it for different
reasons in different ways thanks for the
Super Chat from Kate Lyons thanks to the
Super Chat from Kyle Peck who says do
you think we'll see well that's uh you
know while you're asking about the
stocks and I won't spoil anything but um
yeah we can anticipate a little bit of
Stark action in this TV show uh thanks
for the Super Chat from fighty Spence
who notices the cats board dagger thanks
for the Super Chat from Jordan who says
Shalom loving the streams you're the
best thank you Jordan thanks for the
Super Chat from Ash who says did mazaria
have that big of a role in the books uh
so far it is fairly faithful I mean it
is there is an interesting difference
with mazaria here because in the show
Daemon says I got mazaria pregnant and
I'm gonna marry her
um and in the books uh he never says
he's gonna marry her but interestingly
the books say that mazaria did get
pregnant whereas in the show mazaria
says that she cannot get pregnant which
is interesting and I think that that
might be an example of the history books
being wrong because that's one of the
themes of the Fire and Blood book is
that sometimes what the history books
say is not what really happened
sometimes there are biases sometimes
there are unknowns sometimes there are
no reliable sources and so I think that
they may be sort of playing with that a
little bit the idea that you know
outwardly Daemon said I got mazaria
pregnant and she's going to be my wife
and masary is like that's not [ __ ]
true but you know that might be what the
history books say because that was
that's what was said publicly so I think
that they may continue to play with that
thanks for the Super Chat from the big
who says could the success of this show
prompt George Martin to hurry up and
finish wins so that he can film that too
yeah I mean George Malden is talking
about creating a Game of Thrones
Cinematic Universe George Martin the
author has compared himself to George
Lucas which uh I find upsetting
um because you know it seems us
backwards George Martin has not finished
the main book series of Game of Thrones
and that's part of why Game of Thrones
uh season 8 and the latest seasons of
Game of Thrones were wide deadly
disliked by a lot of people but they ran
out of books to adapt
and I think it is pretty crazy to be
making more prequels and even more
sequel shows George is talking about
making a Jon Snow sequel spin-off TV
show with kit Harrington but he hasn't
even written the ending of the main
Thrones book yet like this is this is
like if George Lucas made the Star Wars
prequels before he finished Return of
the Jedi like it it is literally like
that it is it is like if we got the
Mandalorian TV show and we got the Clone
Wars TV show and we got the [ __ ] bad
batch and all of that stuff before
George Lucas had finished the Original
Trilogy of Star Wars movies that's how
asked backwards this is and George
Martin has said like oh yes oh I know
the Winds of Winter is very late and I'm
trying my best to finish it
um it's been 11 years George
um and he also talks about how you know
the spin-off shows are distracting him
from The Winds of Winter because George
Martin is involved in House of the
dragon and all these other shows and he
talks about how when he's working on
those other shows he finds it difficult
to focus on the Winds of Winter so I
think that there is a very unfortunate
this is a very unfortunate situation and
it is self-inflicted by George I think
largely I mean I think partly he is a
sort of a tortured creative he's a
perfectionist and the Winds of Winter is
an incredibly difficult riding challenge
because there are so many plot lines so
much going on in the books that is not
even in the show at all maybe it's an
impossible challenge maybe it is
impossible to end the Game of Thrones
books at least you know within two more
books which is what George wants to do
so um yeah look it is frustrating but I
wish Georgia all the best and I hope
that we get to read The Winds of Winter
one day thanks for the Super Chat from
your boy who says viserys tells Corliss
I am your king yeah we did that one
um thanks for the Super Chat from Paul
who says do you think they will expand
on forging Valyrian steel yeah so
Valyrian steel is the special magic
super strong steel that was made in
valyria
uh hundreds of years ago and when
Valeria exploded uh the secret of
forging Valyrian steel was lost uh they
can reforge and reshape Valyrian steel
like they did uh with Ned Stark's
Valyrian steel sword ice the Lannisters
melted it down and turned it into oath
keeper and widow's whale the swords of
Brienne and Joffrey
um so you can you can change the form
and the shape of Valyrian steel but you
cannot
um
you cannot make a new Valyrian steel so
those Valyrian steel swords that exist
are extremely valuable and that becomes
relevant later in Game of Thrones
because Valyrian steel swords can kill
White Walkers so they're very valuable
for that reason
um so it's kind of interesting that in
House of the Dragon Daemon gives Rainier
this little Valyrian steel pendant this
little necklace
um it's only like a tiny bit of Valyrian
steel so I guess it's not a waste and
also like the maesters the maesters wear
those chains with links of many
different Metals
um and in the books one of those links
is made of Valyrian steel and what that
represents is that that maester has
learned about magic
uh but my point is that you have
Valyrian steel super valuable super
mysterious because no one knows how
Valyrian steel is made there are lots of
different theories like maybe Valyrian
steel is made with dragon fire maybe
Valyrian steel is made with obsidian or
or dragonglass uh there's lots of
different ideas on how Valyrian steel
might be made and maybe that'll be
revealed later in the books as a way to
make more Valyrian steel in the books uh
there's one guy who has a Valyrian steel
arak the the curved Dothraki blade which
is pretty cool uh the celticars have a
Valyrian steel ax in uh in the books
lots of cool Valyrian swords
um and there is an ALT shift x video
about the all the Valyrian steel swords
in the books that you can check out if
you'd like but yeah
um it is a mystery how it's made and
it's interesting that this show is
revealing stuff about Valyrian Mysteries
and Valyrian law so hell maybe we will
learn more I thought this line was also
very interesting when viserys says that
he's he's scared of talking to his
daughter Rainier sometimes uh and he
also and he sort of talks as though he's
kind he was kind of scared of valerion
as well because valerion was the biggest
and oldest Dragon viserys rode balerion
for a while but then valerion died of
old age and it's sort of interesting the
way viserys talks about valerion as
though valerion is scary to him and I
think that sort of makes a lot of sense
metaphorically because the dragons
represent power and viserys talks as
though he's sort of afraid of power
viserys doesn't really want power I mean
there was that line
um where someone told viserys that like
you know when you're King you have claim
to everything even if you don't want
those things you know
um to be a king you have to assert your
power even if you don't really want to
take over everything like viserys
doesn't care about the stepstones but he
has to assert power of the stepstones
otherwise he'll be seen as weak and
people will take other [ __ ] from him so
yeah I thought that was cool uh thanks
for the Super Chat from Eason who says I
feel bad for viserys thanks for the
Super Chat from Heather and from dph who
says can you explain which dragons there
are slash who rode them before Daemon
and Rainier uh yeah so these dragons all
have a history
um caraxis was written by was it Balon
or was it aemon uh I can figure this out
because yeah like all these dragons like
they they live longer than humans most
of them
um and so in the family trees that
there's like um
there's a history explaining which
dragons were written by who in the past
um
so you know they mentioned dream fire
this episode like the egg that Daemon
Stole was dreamfires egg and dream fire
was the dragon of Reina Targaryen who
was the elder sister of King joharis
um and she had some cool Adventures on
karaxi's
um Vega who is the giant oldest Dragon
who Lena valerion talks about
um Vega was originally the dragon of
Queen visenya Targaryen who was sort of
the stronger and scarier and more
martial of aegon targaryen's wives
um
so yeah there's a history to all of
these dragons
and that sort of says things about the
personalities of the people who ride
them I think and like rainey's rides
millise the Red Queen uh Cyrax is a
young dragon rhaenyra is the first
writer of Cyrax because Cyrax is like a
fairly recent hatchling so Cyrax is
still growing
um and may become even more big and
fearsome in the future
and yeah valerion is dead so we're not
going to see Valerian but like there are
heaps of dragons so we'll be introducing
them as they appear in the show
thanks for the Super Chat from Amanda
who mentions the on the next episode
thing
um we will talk about that towards the
end of the stream thanks for the Super
Chat from John and from merciful who
says did anyone else notice lady Lena
only really caring about finding out
where vagar nests yeah I think we we
talked about it's really cool Elena is
interested in Vega that I mean and she's
clearly not into marrying this this old
dude obviously uh because she's 12.
um but I thought but that sort of
corresponds to a line in the book where
they say that you know Lena is not
interested in boys she's interested in
dragons so this is in keeping with her
personality uh Lane is described as
being fiery and adventurous just like
her parents call us and rhaenys so it's
gonna be cool to see where what what
Elena gets up to next thanks for the
Super Chat from jinsai karuki who says
viserys is so ineffective I'm surprised
no one has called him out on being
Otto's puppet yeah I'm surprised that
like Corliss hasn't said that you know
because cordless is a rival of of Otto
and it is so obvious in the council that
Otto is sort of overriding and
manipulating viserys I I guess it I am
surprised that Corliss doesn't just say
hey like viserys like Otto is using you
I mean Daemon said that last episode
Daemon said to viserys hey
Otto is ambitious he's scheming he's
he's playing you
um maybe Corliss doesn't say it because
you know he's scared that Otto could
push him out of power you know like no
one wants to criticize Otto because Otto
will just uh kick you out and we'll move
the king against you I think that's
plausible thanks for the Super Chat from
Liam who says can you explain the other
Dragon Yeah well vegar yeah like I said
vegar is the biggest oldest Dragon
um and was originally the dragon of
Xenia and is now AWOL who's just hanging
out on a beach somewhere and Lena is
interested in Vega that's what we know
about so far uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Brian who says question for
the end will we get a Westworld season 4
video I'm not intending on making alt
shift decks Westworld season 4 videos I
would have liked to but uh there just
wasn't time with House of the dragon and
stuff
um thanks for the Super Chat from Kate
who says please say Joe's not a good man
Kate's the best woman thanks for the
Super Chat from worldwide who says do
you think there should be more comedic
relief personally no I like the fairies
serious tone I mean I mean some of
daemon's lines are hilarious you know so
crisp and like you know like daemon's
entire Vibe itself is like a comic
relief almost just just all of his [ __ ]
stirring and provoking I mean personally
I disliked a lot of the comedic relief
in the later seasons of Game of Thrones
all the stuff where like you know Braun
was grabbing people's balls and pycell
was fighting and Braun was giving
Podrick a noogie and Tyrion and Varys
were talking about balls and dicks all
the time I I didn't enjoy that very much
in the later seasons of Thrones um and I
think the serious tone Works in House of
the Dragon
um I like I don't like the sort of
marvelization of everything becoming
self-referential and everything becoming
a joke because then it just becomes not
a story you can engage with it just
becomes a meme and you know I don't like
that sort of pandering sometimes so yeah
I I think it's got the right amount of
levity which is not much uh thanks for
the Super Chat from d3m who says do you
think the cuts from the throne could be
part of a maester conspiracy yeah we
mentioned that idea maybe the maesters
are actually
trying to make viserys get worse and die
so that they can replace him with you
know uh rhaenyra and maybe they want to
control rhaenyra or something but you
know Otto's plan is to marry viserys to
Alison to have a child by Alison and
Otto and Melos are working together so
so you know I would think that the
maesters would want viserys to stay
alive at least long enough to uh produce
an air with the elephant if there's a
conspiracy going on maybe there isn't a
big conspiracy going on maybe the
conspiracy is just Otto and Melos
looking out for each other's backs
thanks for the Super Chat from spiced
who says coreless rocks I like the
directness of callus I like the honesty
of callers like in a world where
everybody else is scheming and lying and
manipulating calluses just like hey you
should marry my daughter because I'm
powerful and you're powerful and it'll
make us both more powerful and he wants
to get [ __ ] done and he says what he
feels and you know I think that we can
get behind him for that for sure thanks
for the Super Chat uh from wealthwolf
who says moment of silence for viserys's
mustache thanks for the Super Chat from
rudulos who says ubu shift Senpai thanks
for the Super Chat from Kings and
Generals uh who has a YouTube channel
that you should check out who says good
episode again but again I feel like
they're rushing a bit
um they should give more
characterization I I feel like they're
doing a lot of characterization I feel
like the characterization of viserys is
great with all of his dithering and his
indecisiveness and the tragedy of him
having good intentions but making bad
decisions I think the characterization
of Allison is good how they're showing
how she is going along with these really
uncomfortable situations with like
viserys and rhaenyra her loyalties are
divided that she's trying to obey her
father and she's trying to be the noble
lady they told her to be but it's making
her so uncomfortable that she's picking
at her fingers I think it's interesting
that like Allison's fingers she's
picking them apart similar to how this
saris's finger is rotting like they both
use their hands to communicate their
inner feelings which I think is
interesting
um I think the characterization of
cordless is great I think the
characterization of Auto with all of his
sort of like like one of the things I
like about Otto is that he's sort of got
this long-suffering Vibe about him like
Otto you can tell he is so sick of
having to put up with daemon's [ __ ]
like especially last episode when Daemon
was like insulting his dead wife and
just doing all this crap to stir up Otto
and Otto just has to put up with it
because Daemon is the King's brother and
like you sort of get the sense that Otto
feels very disrespected and he's sort of
plotting to get back at everyone who
disrespected him and to advance his
family and like he you know it's not for
no reason that he's putting up with
everything he wants this to pay off for
him in the end because he's a second son
and he's not going to be Lord of Old
Town so he needs to make his own legacy
so
so you know I feel like they're
characterizing everyone really well in
my opinion but um you know they
certainly could do more
um
I feel like I feel like Rainier I feel
like sometimes I'm not totally sold on
Rainier's performance
um but I think generally it's all pretty
good thanks for the Super Chat from
Philippe who says did you get a chance
to see the episode 3 preview we will
show that and discuss that at the end of
the live stream Greg thanks for the
donation says where is mushroom so
mushroom is a Jester he is viserys's
Jester in the Game of Thrones books
um here's some artwork by Rossi does
drawings and uh mushroom is reputed to
have a gigantic head and a gigantic
member
um and mushroom is one of the historical
sources in the Fire and Blood book that
this show is based on and while septin
Eustis is always saying oh you know this
happened for totally reasonable reasons
mushroom is always saying they secretly
boned that person secretly murdered that
other person that person through that
other person out a window like there's
all this crazy [ __ ] the mushroom is
saying all the time
and so some readers have speculated like
will we get to see Mushroom in the show
like it makes sense that we would
because he was he was there in the books
um and there was an interview uh by
westeros.org I think of Ryan Condell the
co-show runner where Ryan Condell said
yes we will see mushroom
so
apparently we will see mushroom I'm very
excited I I I I mean we were talking
before about like comedic moments uh
mushroom will be funny mushroom is a
Jester mushroom says ridiculous [ __ ] all
the time
um so if you're looking for levity we
will get it if mushroom turns up I would
think or maybe it's just gonna be a
cameo maybe we're just going to see a
dwarf Jester in the background at some
point and maybe that's that's all it'll
be but um yeah I am excited to hopefully
see mushroom thanks for the Super Chat
from paramvir who says could House of
the Dragon jump to blackfyre stuff after
the dance
yeah so
so so uh this story of the House of the
Dragon uh is about a conflict called the
dance of the dragons and the creators
have said that it'll likely take about
three or four seasons of House of the
Dragon to tell the story from beginning
to end
and they've also said that you know if
House of the Dragon is popular they
might get to do other time periods
because George Martin has written some
300 years of Targaryen history and there
are many other interesting similar
conflicts such as the blackfyre
rebellions with a young Barry the Bold
seen here slaying males the Monstrous a
dude with two heads
um which all started when a terrible
King called aegon the Unworthy decided
to legitimize all his bastards as a sort
of a [ __ ] you to the entire continent
and generations of Bloodshed followed
and uh the sword blackfyre that we see
viserys
using and holding at least in House of
the Dragon this sword is at the center
of that conflict so there's lots of
connective tissue so um
so the answer is yes like the
co-creators have said that they may get
to cover other conflicts in other time
periods in House of the Dragons so it
could become a sort of a Anthology uh
jumping around through time uh they
could cover you know the valyrians uh on
Dragonstone or like the targaryens on
Dragonstone they could do Robert's
Rebellion when big Bobby B took over
Westeros all sorts of potential for
really cool shows thanks for the Super
Chat from absolute who says need more
content in the shows about a shy and the
shadowlands Mysteries yeah a shy is the
most distant and most mysterious and and
dark and spooky Place uh in the world of
Ice and Fire I mean I think that a shy
is more fun when it's mysterious I think
that if all the mysteries of ishai were
explained it might make it might be less
cool it's like Lovecraft stuff it's
better when it's not explained
um you know you don't need to know who
cthulhu's dad is and where he buys his
groceries in order to make him an
interesting character
um
but
shy is super cool I mean Melisandre came
from a shy Marwan the Mage visited ashai
um and
went to wish I the witch who uh who was
with Daenerys in Game of Thrones season
one
um there's all sorts of crazy stuff that
goes on in a shy and there's all these
theories about like maybe the great
Empire of the Dawn built a shy because
ashai is made out of this oily Black
Stone which is like super mysterious and
spooky and it's like why would someone
build a giant City out of spooky oily
Black Stone maybe the lovecraftian fishy
deep ones built it maybe it was
originally normal but it got corrupted
by the Bloodstone Emperor there's all
sorts of cool [ __ ] going on
thanks for the Super Chat from Gabriella
who says your videos are fire thank you
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Eason
who says have you talked about why Rey
was upset with viserys about Alison yeah
so rhaenyra is upset that King viserys
is marrying her best friend Alison
because well I think anyone would be
upset about their dad marrying their
best friend it's just a very sort of
awkward situation when your best friend
becomes your stepmom
um and I think part of it is that
viserys and Allison didn't tell Rainier
about this before it happened like maybe
if Alison and or viserys like sat down
with rhaenyra and was like Hey we're
making this marriage this is why this is
how we feel about it we're going to
listen to your feelings about it you
know maybe if they talked about it it
would have made sense because like keep
in mind like you know viserys told
Alison hey don't tell my daughter that
we are seeing each other so it's a
secret it's explicitly a secret kept
from rhaenyra and viserys didn't tell
Rainier this and Allison didn't tell
Rainier this and so I think that
rhaenyra feels betrayed I think she
feels confused I think she feels
overwhelmed like you know maybe she will
be
a bit more relaxed about it later but I
think that in the moment the initial
shock is like what the [ __ ] is this and
of course it's also a threat to rhaenyra
politically because if viserys has
children those children could
potentially replace rhaenyra as out of
the throne that's what rhaenys tells her
so I think that reigning era has a lot
of good reasons to feel upset about this
marriage
thanks for the Super Chat from
Christopher who says what would you do
if when Rainier you okay so he said yes
would go
uh my dude you need some punctuation
thanks for the Super Chat from Ramon who
says why the targaryens didn't fly their
dragons west of Westeros to see where it
goes while it's funny you should say
that because rainy's Targaryen The
sister wife of aegon the Conqueror did
want to fly west of Westeros
um that was a dream of hers
his artwork by amok
um there have been several people who
have asked what is west of Westeros
because it's just a sort of a blank spot
on the map
um here's the known world you got
Westeros in the west here you got airsos
in the East here you got sethorios the
weird jungle continent in the South
you've got the ulthos which is like the
bloody New Zealand of The Song of Ice
and Fire
um no one knows what's west of Westeros
there is this tiny little island lonely
light which is where
um like a hundred walruses and one
ironborn family live and that's as far
west as as we know there is a woman
called Alyssa farman in Fire and Blood
who does exactly that she sails West
because she wants to discover what's out
there
and Alyssa farman found a few Islands
West and West and West of lonely light a
few little Islands
um and her mates were like okay well
that's far enough for us we're gonna go
home but Alyssa kept going west and
Corliss valerion the sea snake when he
went on his voyages he went as far east
as Yeti and a shy and Corliss said that
when callus went to a shy he saw Alyssa
farman's ship the sun chaser
so it seems that apparently Alyssa
farman according to Corliss actually
succeeded in going all the way west of
Westeros that she came in from the East
and arrived at ishai so maybe Alyssa did
discover these you know mysterious
continents on the other side of the
world maybe she saw [ __ ] what happened
to her we don't know some people say we
were talking about quaith before some
people believe that quaff is Alyssa
farman
maybe she became a model somehow using
like ashayi magic because Kuwait in the
books tells Daenerys to go west you must
go east which sort of suggests like
circumnavigating the world right which
is exactly what Alyssa farman did
Alyssa went West to reach the East you
know so all sorts of weird theories
there
um and if you want to learn about Alyssa
farman uh you can get the audiobook of
Fire and Blood uh with a free trial at
audible.com ASX
that's not a link
audible doc yeah [ __ ] whatever go
check out the sponsor link anyway uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Ramon who
says uh thanks for the Super Chat from
Clarence who says I don't get why Alison
was in the room for the betrothal
announcement why would anyone be shocked
if it's her if she's already there yeah
I mean I would have thought that you
know Rainier would have seen Alison in
the room from the beginning and gone uh
why is Alison at the small council
meeting she's not normally here but I
mean you know they wanted her in the
room to make a more dramatic and
emotional so they can have some eye
contact
UM thanks for the Super Chat from Chip
chaps who says uh explain the last convo
between Daemon and Corliss uh okay so
basically
um Daemon was pierced that
um he that he was kicked out of
Dragonstone he's pissed off that viserys
rejected him last episode he's pissed
off that he's not the heir to the throne
he's gonna be super pissed off that
viserys is now marrying Allison and will
have more heirs to move him even further
back in the line of succession uh Daemon
has a lot of feelings and he wants to do
something and Corliss is extremely
frustrated because uh viserys did not
marry his daughter Lena like he wanted
which would have been enormously
beneficial to house for Larry on his
family politically so Daemon and Corliss
are too like badasses who are pissed off
and they feel alienated from King's
Landing and it's like well let's start
our own party with Blackjack and hookers
so they're saying okay let's go and
fight this crab [ __ ] that's what
they're doing call us in Daemon or like
well you know if we can't be ears to the
throne if we can't be close to King
viserys if we we can't have places of
power and honor at court we'll we'll do
our own thing and so they are deciding
to go and fight crab ass crab feeder who
is this Eastern dude from the triarchy
who's taken over the stepstones which
are these uh little Islands here in
between Westeros and essos they
mentioned Bloodstone so they they're
going to go and fight uh Mr Krabs
thanks for the Super Chat from
guillermere
sorry for mispronouncing who says I've
been loving the valerians thank God
nothing bad will ever happen to them
look I'm just happy that nothing bad
will happen to any of the characters in
this story and that they're all going to
get along and have good times together
and be respectful and loving and
communicative thanks for the Super Chat
from Syed who says is visenya still
alive no vicenya is dead visenya died a
long time ago
um aegon the Conqueror and his sisters
of senya and rainy so they died ages ago
um 100 you know like 70 years ago or
something
um
and
vicenya's Dragon Vega lives on however
thanks to the Super Chat from Ron Sands
who says any chance we see Duncan the
tall get an HBO series yeah so dunk and
egg are a series of novellas written by
George Martin about a knight and his
Squire and they are great and fun and
they go on adventures together
um here's some art by Mel amundsen he
has some art by sheb's Art Duncan egg
are just great their stories are much
more sort of small scale than the
stories of Game of Thrones
um like they're not fighting in battles
to save the world they're just like
traveling and going to tournaments and
you know occasionally interrupting
blackfyre Rebellion but mostly just just
hanging
um and there is there have been reports
that HBO has done work developing a
Duncan egg show and I think that could
potentially be cool but George RR Martin
has only written three Duncan egg
novellas when he says it's going to take
10 or 12 novellas to tell their full
story so I think it would be a very bad
idea to start making a Duncan egg TV
show before the books are finished just
like the Game of Thrones show started
before the Game of Thrones books are
finished and we all saw how that turned
out thanks for the super chip Super Chat
from will Berger who also has a cool
YouTube channel that you should check
out who says yo seems like the show
writers are leaning into the mystery of
blood magic the opening and viserys
talking about blood Mages where can the
show take that is it wrong to give the
mystery away
yeah it's a good question like like how
is ancient Valyrian blood magic relevant
to the dance of the dragons and Fire and
Blood uh I'm not going to spoil anything
but like that is a little puzzling to me
maybe they're gonna make changes I mean
there there are some bits and pieces in
Fire and Blood about magic that I think
they potentially could expand into being
more significant I mean I think the main
reason they're talking about valyria is
that you know they're talking about the
fall and the decline of valyria which
sort of connects to the potential
decline of the targaryens
um but yeah it's it is weird they're
talking about blood Mages so much and
it's weird that they're talking about
um like the name of the Valyrian city
um that they mentioned anogri on what
the [ __ ] is an inaugurion that's not in
the books I I think honestly like what
it might be is that they invented a
bunch of law about valyria for the
valyria TV show that got developed but
never got made and I think George Garden
probably got really excited writing
about this stuff but then the law
who was not used because the valyria
show got canceled
it never got made into a show
um and so maybe they just had this cool
lore lying around and George was like
hey hey Ryan Condell you should talk
about enogrion and since Ryan is a
massive [ __ ] nerd he was like yeah we
should definitely talk about inaugurion
then the HBO executives are like what
what's inaugurion and Ryan and George
were like it's really important trust us
with their fingers crossed behind their
back I think maybe that is what happened
thanks for the Super Chat from dust who
says Auto be like I just need 20 good
men yeah
yeah I guess the more you think about it
the more absurd it is that Otto
Hightower came to Dragonstone with like
10 Dragon Keepers and and Kristen Cole
and Grand maester Melos and was like
yeah this is totally gonna be sufficient
to convince Daemon to give up and come
home I mean I I guess you know maybe you
can credit Otto for you know he didn't
want to attack immediately you know he
wanted to attempt a diplomatic solution
which is probably the better thing to do
you know like maybe Otto was absolutely
prepared to attack if need be and I
think he was
um but like not right away he he gave
peace a chance
um and I think I guess Otto Knows that
like if Otto like killed Daemon or
whatever viserys would be really pissed
and might fire Otto or something so you
know Otto is trying to be smart about
this
um and we speculated before that maybe
Otto you know maybe Otto secretly sent
some other soldiers around the back way
to climb up the walls of Dragonstone and
you know capture a hostage or something
but um but yeah it does seem kind of
silly that Otto thinks that Daemon is
going to listen to him because when has
Daemon ever listened to Otto Hightower
thanks for the Super Chat from Matt who
says in your recent vid you pointed out
how Arya killed the night King therefore
the prophecy is untrue but didn't Jon
and dany's actions contribute big time
yeah so last episode viserys told
Rainier that aegon Targaryen The
Conqueror had a dream about white
walkers and that's why he conquered
Westeros because he believed that only a
Targaryen on the Iron Throne could unite
Westeros and save the world from the
White Walkers and in uh Game of Thrones
in our house of the Dragon season 1
episode 1 explained video we said that
he was wrong in the sense that there was
not a Targaryen on the iron throne and
Westeros was not United
um so he so he was wrong about that but
like you're right that John who is a
Targaryen through rhaegar Targaryen and
Daenerys Targaryen yeah they did play an
instrumental role in getting a bunch of
people together uh uniting like not all
of Westeros but uniting some of Westeros
to fight against the White Walkers and
you know John and Danny Targaryen did
play a role at the battle against the
white walkers in season eight episode
three
so yeah like maybe without the
targaryens maybe IO would never have
been able to kill the night King so so
yeah like I'm not trying to say that
aegon was totally wrong like aegon was
right that the targaryens had some role
to play in defeating the white walkers
um an important role but but you know he
specifically said or at least visery
specifically said there must be a
Targaryen on the iron throne in order to
save the world and that did not turn out
to be true because Cersei Lannister was
on the throne so you know like it's
meant to be ambiguous like it's not just
aegon right or aegon wrong it's a bit
complicated it's subject to
interpretation and that's how all the
dreams and the prophecies are in the
books
um it's never going to be simple so you
know it we can have multiple
interpretations here thanks to the Super
Chat from a Taha who said what do you
think of the episode
um I mean you know I try and make alt
shift X about you know what happened
what's in the books what's in the text
what does it mean I you know it's not
about my opinion you'll conform your own
opinion but uh look I enjoyed it I I
very much enjoyed squeaky flying worm
dog caraxis I thought that was
enormously fun
um and I think that they're doing a good
job of adapting the book I mean the book
has not a lot of detail in it and I
think they're doing a good job of
creating details that are new
um and which add things to the story
without like [ __ ] up the story like I
think look it's a whole lot better than
the later seasons of Game of Thrones
I'll say that thanks for the Super Chat
from Brenda uh no I don't think the
second son's uh the mercenary company is
super relevant here uh thanks for the
Super Chat from Molina and from R and
from Molina who says do you believe
rhaenyra and Kristen uh I'm not going to
spoil anything about the future
all right um so what else haven't we
talked about
um I thought this sept was interesting
because uh Rainier and Alison go to
church together uh which is cute
um and I thought it was cool how you
know Allison was sort of teaching
rhaenyra how to pray and teaching her
about the seven because I guess the
targaryens are not super devout but the
high towers are
um and it's interesting that it was set
in this sept here I don't know which
sept that is because in the Game of
Thrones TV show they have balor's sept
which is the biggest sept in King's
Landing but that was built by King Balor
who comes much after House of the Dragon
and before that there was the sept of
remembrance which was originally the
biggest except in King's Landing but
King maegor the cruel burned that with
valerion when he went to war against the
church
so
so I don't know what this sept in
between is I guess it's just some new
sept some Royal sept that they've
invented I mean there is a sept in the
red keep in the books
um but this is some other sept but
anyway you know like I like how in the
faith of the seven they have these sort
of seven archetypes of the father and
the Smith and the warrior and the maid
and the Crone and the mother and the
stranger who will sort of represent
different parts of the human experience
different archetypes different social
roles and people come into the sept and
they light a candle to one of the seven
um so sometimes soldiers light a candle
to the warrior and you know young women
lighter candles the maid and rhaenyra
and elephant light candles to them to
the mother because they have both lost
their mothers and they want to reconnect
with their mothers and so I think that's
a obviously a deep connection that
Alison have Alison and Rainier have is
that they've both lost their mothers
um and it's always cool to see a
religion play a part because like there
wasn't a lot of that in the Game of
Thrones original show even though it's
important in the books
um I thought it was really cool that the
opening shot of this episode after the
opening sequence uh was this red wine
being poured and after the bloody red
bloodstream in the opening sequence this
looks like blood and I think blood is is
definitely a a motif or a symbol that
they're reusing because blood implies
death it implies life it implies family
it implies lineage all of which are
Super relevant to this story so I
thought that was cool
um I thought that it was sweet that
viserys like you know he shows uh care
for the death of Ryan
um like viserys you know says that he
passed in peace I hope and it's just
it's just a little thing but it shows
that viserys cares about people
um like he's not very good at being a
king but like he does genuinely you know
care about people's well-being even if
he's not always good at relationships he
does try thanks to the Super Chat from
Gabrielle who asks about Melisandre
Melisandre is very old and she might be
alive in this time period but I don't
think it's likely that Melisandre will
appear in House of the Dragon
um and so we got this scene of rhaenyra
overseeing or like choosing a new
kingsguard to replace uh Ryan redwine
and so we get all these houses like
that's Karen mallister corbree Craig
Hall tarly all these houses from around
the realm send a night and says hey this
guy should be on the king's God and I
liked how it starts with rhaenyra
standing on this little footstool
uh this footstool well she's standing on
a footstool and it sort of shows how
young and small she is just to highlight
her young age and you know Rainier makes
this point that we shouldn't just be
hiring Knights that are good at
tournaments to be on the King's Guard we
should be hiring Knights who have
actually fought in real battles and then
Otto is like well there might be
political reasons why we should choose a
certain night and that's sort of how the
king's God becomes corrupt in some ways
because the kingsguard is meant to be
the seven best warriors in the realm
um but sometimes that gets corrupted and
people get chosen for political reasons
or for like personal relationship
reasons
um and by the time of the Game of
Thrones show
the King's Guard is pretty [ __ ] you got
all these [ __ ] like boros blonde
that are just like not good Fighters and
it's like why are they here
um so
yeah it's interesting that Rainier is
trying to stand up and say hey no they
should actually be good Fighters and I
thought it was really cool seeing
rhaenys oversee this like rhaenys is
just watching rhaenyra and going man
like this is history repeating itself
Rainier is going to be excluded just
like I was excluded uh because you know
she was sent from the council because
she was trying to speak and give advice
but with viserys and Otto sort of
patronizingly said no you go do you go
play you do something else you go pick
the King's Guard whatever
um and you know that's so unfair because
you know Corliss was talking back to
viserys Otto was talking back to viserys
like everyone was like speaking their
mind adversaris kind of rudely in some
ways uh but when rhaenyra did it she got
sent out of the room so it shows how
even though rhaenyra is supposedly the
heir to the throne and should be like
having a voice and should be learning at
least but viserys just sees her as his
little girl and he's protective of her
and he doesn't give her a chance to
assert herself
thanks to the Super Chat from Nelly who
says isn't there another player named
Amon in history look there's there's a
bunch of people called aemon Targaryen
there's at least three people uh four
called Amon Targaryen
um and you might be thinking of maester
Eamon Targaryen in the main Game of
Thrones books who was at Castle black
and is a mentor to John but um yeah look
that there's there's many people with
the same names I think there's like 11
characters called aegon Targaryen
um and Jon Snow is Apparently one of
them in the Game of Thrones show so uh
so yeah there are many people with the
same names and George Martin did that
because that's what real medieval
history is like all these King Georges
and King Edwards and all of that so he's
trying to be true to history or maybe he
just um got sick of making up new names
thanks for the Super Chat from Anthony
who says was the crab feeder in the book
yes the crab feeder is in the book but
you know it doesn't say like a whole lot
of detail about him so the show is
making up you know the mask and his
appearance and his Vibe and stuff so
it'll be really cool to see what else
they had thanks for the Super Chat from
Mod Mary who says how big a part does
viserys's fear of dragons play in the
choices he has made and Otto's ability
to manipulate him yeah I think that is
really interesting like like that it
sort of isn't explicitly there in the
books but like it does make a lot of
sense the viserys you know he once rode
the biggest scariest most powerful
Dragon in the world he he rode the most
powerful weapon of War ever and he we
wasn't really all that into it
apparently like he seems kind of scared
of the black dread and he said last
episode that dragons are a power that
man never should have trifled with and
you know the idea that we control the
dragons is an illusion you know so he he
his overwhelming feeling is that power
is dangerous you know I mean he knows
about valyria right and he sort of says
He suggests that dragons are what
destroyed valyria which is not strictly
true in the books like the books don't
say that necessarily but the point is
that power can lead to your downfall and
viserys is very aware of that and he's
in the process of doing that I think
through his bad decisions
um so so yeah look and I think that
that's you can also connect that to the
idea of like are the maesters and the
hightowers opposed to dragons because
like obviously like if like there was a
line that Lionel strong said in this
episode where he said that you know the
King on the Iron Throne of Westeros is
on the highest seat in the land and
proud men don't like looking up
meaning that Lords are jealous Lords
don't like it when someone is more
powerful than them and whoever has
dragons is more powerful than anyone who
doesn't have dragons so like pretty much
everyone who isn't the targaryens hates
dragons and like fair enough because the
whole book Fire and Blood is basically a
list of reasons why dragons suck for
everyone who doesn't have dragons and
even for the people who do have dragons
uh you know like during aegon's Conquest
like it's funny that in the last episode
they're like oh you know aegon was just
trying to save the world from the White
Walkers and that's why he took over
Westeros but it's like my dude like
aegon killed tens of thousands maybe a
hundred thousand people in his Wars this
is the Field of Fire where the armies of
the reach and the Lannisters came to
oppose the targaryens uh and the
targaryens just burned the [ __ ] out of
like 50 000 men in in one day and it's
like oh this this sucks
it uh it sucks when these like flying
lizards eat people and there's nothing
you can do about it because they're
kings and they've got dragons so I think
that the idea that dragons make you
all-powerful but they all they also make
you a Target
if you're on the throne you're the most
powerful person in the world but that's
the most dangerous seat in the world
because people want to replace you and I
think that sort of comes back to the
blood imagery that they keep using and
just the Iron Throne itself you know any
kind of power is dangerous and it can
destroy you and that is definitely one
of the themes that they're playing with
here thanks for the Super Chat from
Alexander who says did Otto pimp his
daughter essentially yeah I think that
the reason why Otto told Alison to put
on her mother's dress and visit the
newly single King viserys in his
Chambers is because Otto wants Alison to
seduce and eventually marry King viserys
so that the hightowers can become more
powerful and that Alison hightower's
children can potentially become Kings
and Queens on the iron throne
so yeah I think that is Otto's plan I
think an interesting question is like
how much does Alison know that that's
what Otto wants like I think Alison does
know that Otto wants her to seduce
viserys and marry him or at least she
very strongly suspects that but it's
interesting that they don't really make
it explicit like what exactly Alison
knows like to what extent is she sort of
being manipulative to what extent is she
just being naive and doing what she's
told to what extent does she have any
choice in this you know like like did
like when visera said I'm gonna marry
Allison she looks a little bit surprised
like did Alison's like did viserys ask
Alison like hey like do you want to
marry me like would would you like that
or would that be scary to you like what
do you want did he ask it doesn't seem
like visiris asked anyone like maybe
viserys asked Otto if he was cool with
viserys marrying his daughter to which
Otto would have replied a very
enthusiastic yes
um but but what you know what what is
Allison's agency here is I think an open
question
thanks for the Super Chat from Molina
who says I like sir Kristen uh yep and I
very much enjoy the Rivalry with Daemon
as well yeah uh Dopey Dragon thanks for
the Super Chat says I adored the
colorful tabards and the heraldry and
stuff yeah so um there was an article
saying that um George Martin
made several requests to the creators of
House of the Dragon
um and one of George Martin's specific
requests something he wanted in House of
the Dragon was colorful heraldry because
there wasn't a lot of that in Game of
Thrones the TV show especially the later
Seasons everyone was wearing black
clothes
towards the end of Game of Thrones and
there was very little heraldry whereas
in the books like everyone has these
crazy helmets and all this drip and
bling and everyone's got their house
colors because like that's how you
communicate who's important and who is
allied with which house and like who is
Rich and who is powerful if you have
like colorful cool clothes that means
you're rich and Powerful so you better
believe the Lords are showing that off
and George Martin loves that [ __ ] George
Martin loves the romance of it and the
fantasy of it and the excitement of it
so I think it's good that they brought
that back like it House of the dragon is
like the original Game of Thrones show
was sort of embarrassed to be a fantasy
show sometimes like the show Runners DND
said something about like you know we
want to appeal to
um football fans and soccer moms not
just to nerds or something
um and they sort of minimize the fantasy
stuff they took out most of the prophecy
they took out most of the magic they
that they tried to take away the fantasy
out of the [ __ ] greatest fantasy of
the last 30 years so it's it's silly and
I like that how's the dragon is starting
to bring that back
thanks for the Super Chat from uh
Gabriella who says that's a great point
about Alison helping teach Rainier about
the seven what gods do the dragonlords
give homage a homage
so so the the targaryens like the
targaryens give lip service to the faith
of the seven for political reasons um
but they're not super religious most of
them except for Baylor the Blessed who
built Bale or serp
um the valyrians before they came to
Westeros worshiped many different gods
but I think it was said in the world of
Ice and Fire that like they worshiped
many but didn't really fully respect any
like the valyrians saw themselves as
gods they did what they wanted because
they had dragons I mean rhaenyra said
last episode that the targaryens are
closer to Gods than to men
so it's because largely of their dragons
that they are special and they are
better than everyone else and so I don't
think they feel the need to worship a
god they prefer to worship themselves
which again obviously sucks for everyone
who isn't a Targaryen you know so yeah a
lot of the targaryens are not super
religious but they pretend to be for
political reasons sometimes thanks for
the Super Chat from chicken power who
says why is there no Westeros table in
Dragonstone yeah so that's a good point
so we had a scene in Dragonstone which
is the island the ancestral home of the
targaryens we saw Stannis and Melisandre
uh cuddle on that on that table in this
room in season two and it's called the
painted table this is a special map that
aegon the Conqueror created
um before he conquered Westeros it's
like this big slab that that shows all
the cities and the castles of Westeros
and it's used as a table which is pretty
cool
um
and yeah you would think that the
painted table would have been visible in
the scene in House of the Dragon but uh
but it's not there which is interesting
has it been moved is it in a different
room I don't know yeah why isn't it
there I'm sure it'll be there at some
point because we have seen it in
trailers thanks for the Super Chat from
Benjamin who says in your opinion what
was the best Targaryen King I mean the
obvious answer for the best Targaryen
King is jahiris because the books kind
of say that he was one of the best
um you know he built infrastructure he
made peace he reconciled with the faith
I mean he was certainly better than
maegor and Anis and and all of that
um I think daeron II was a was a
well-intentioned dude
um who also tried to make peace and do
well but you know that led into the
first blackfyre Rebellion
um I think egg aegon the fifth you know
he tried to give rights to the peasants
and I think that's important
um and you know we don't know much much
about King egg's Reign but I uh he
seemed like he was a good King
um
I think that you know aegon IV was
terrible and I mean Baylor the Blessed
bless his heart was well intentioned in
some ways but catastrophically stupid in
other ways but most of the Kings have
good points and bad points
um but I think Joe Harris was one of the
best thanks for the Super Chat from Sam
K who says good night brother please
remember to offer a prayer and some
respect to our lord of crabs I cannot
wait for the wall of crab emojis uh next
episode when uh the crab feeder turns up
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Brooks
who again asks about the second sons
that is the name of a mercenary group
it's also a line in uh that call us says
I mean I mean that's a recurring idea
throughout the series like the idea of
you know the firstborn son gets to
inherit the castle and the second born
son doesn't and so the second born son
often needs to do some wild [ __ ] to get
their own name in the history books
sometimes they fight Wars or become a
maester or join the Night's Watch or all
sorts of things that second Sons can do
um Oberyn Martell was a second son who
went and caused all sorts of ruckus
overseas and so call us and Demon are
continuing in that tradition by being
annoying younger brothers although
callus is a first-born son I think I
mean he is the Lord of driftmark so
Corliss is not a second son I don't
think uh but daemonies
thanks for the Super Chat from Nelly uh
we're not talking spoilers thanks for
the Super Chat from Paige who says it's
crazy how down Liana was to be married
to the king for a little girl
um Lena Valerian yeah was was uh was
potentially going to marry King viserys
and yeah it is [ __ ] crazy that this
12 year old girl was potentially
marrying this dude in the books viserys
is not as old as Paddy considine
um I think he's like not yet 30 at this
time but yeah it's a it's a huge age Gap
and is very uncomfortable um but this is
something that happens a lot in the Game
of Thrones books uh people marry much
younger children and generally they
don't have sex like yeah like Lena says
I will not have to bed you until I turn
14.
um often the way it works is that after
um they hit puberty and have first
menstrual cycle that's when uh the girl
is considered ready to have sex and
stuff about producing children but
there's also all the stuff about how you
know there are a bunch of characters who
die in childbirth and the maesters say
hey like they had sex too young their
body wasn't ready to give birth
um and like you know Alison's Health was
damaged and Emma Aaron and you know Emma
Aaron's mother so
it you know it is like a common thing in
the books for very young girls to get
married and often soon to have sex and
get pregnant but it also shows that
there's often harm and death and horror
associated with that
um so that may be something they
continue to explore
thanks for the Super Chat from Thomas
who says the style of dragon seems much
more lean and serpent-like than in got
uh well the dragons vary in House of the
Dragon but there's many many dragons in
House of the dragon and we're going to
see more and more of them and the
showrunners say that they're trying to
give each one a distinct look so like
karaxi's looks like a worm with wings
like he is very Serpentine but there's
other dragons who don't look so
Serpentine and we've seen that in
trailers and stuff like with Vega
um so yeah I think I think there'll be a
variety of designs thanks for the Super
Chat and and that is how that is
described in the books in the books the
dragons are different colors like
rhaegal viserion and drogon daenerys's
dragons are each a different color they
even breathe different colored fire like
drogon breathes blackfyre and viserions
is like pale and and rhaegar is like
gold with flecks of green I think
so again like George Martin is always
leaning into the colorful Fantastical
bright and vibrant fantasy and it's nice
to see House of the Dragon uh be
faithful to that thanks for the super
chats from carrion Heather Annabella and
Daniel who says the targaryens are
incredibly religious they just believe
themselves to be Gods yeah that's a good
way to say it thanks for the Super Chat
from Alchemist who says Alison 100 knew
what was going on and why she was asked
to First Comfort viserys she didn't tell
rhaenyra about their talks before
viserys asked
um yeah that's an interesting point like
you know it's been six months Allison
and rhaenyra have presumably been having
their little lunchtime dates for a while
um and viserys now asks Allison not asks
Allison not at her rhaenyra but like I
guess she has never told Rainier at any
point in the last six months I mean
maybe that's just you know the way they
wrote it with the timeline and you know
whatever
um but yeah like like yeah Alison is not
dumb like like she know I think she does
know that Otto is wanting her to marry
viserys but it's like does that mean
she's manipulating viserys or is she
just being there and turning up because
the king is asking to have lunch with
her you know like can we blame Ellison
for doing what she's told or is she
emotionally manipulating people I think
it's kind of ambiguous but I think I
tend to think that you know we see how
uncomfortable Alison is with this
situation we see her picking at her
fingers all the time so she doesn't like
the situation that she's in I think she
feels forced to be in it
thanks for the Super Chat from dust who
says will we see more of the other great
houses I won't spoil anything but like
you know there's there's some Starks
there's some Lannisters there's a bit of
that but it is mostly about the
targaryens and the hightowers and
valerions thanks for the Super Chat from
Jason who says is the Iron Throne
poisoned ah well the books don't say
that the Iron Throne is poisoned but I
mean you know maybe that's why Otto's uh
why viserys's hand has become infected
maybe someone put poison on the Iron
Throne knowing that viserys is
repeatedly cutting himself on the Iron
Throne maybe he maybe it was poisoned or
you know maybe the mesters are putting
poisoning his wounds to make him die and
weak but you know I I think that if the
maesters have a conspiracy
it's a conspiracy with Otto to make
Allison uh and and you know viserys and
Allison
um as the new Power couple of Westeros
like I don't think I don't think anyone
really wants viserys dead at this point
so I don't think anyone's poisoning him
thanks for the Super Chat from Adrian
and Danny and Matt diff who says Ned
Stark was a big second son he would
think he was never meant to rule but
serve also Kevin Lannister yeah those
are other good examples of second Sons
because Ned was the younger brother of
Brandon Stark uh who was going to be the
Lord of Westeros of Winterfell uh but he
got turned into a uh poor crackling by
heiress the Mad King instead and Kevin
Lannister is the dutiful obedient
brother of Tywin carrying out his war
crimes for him
yeah maybe call us had an elder brother
who died and that's why Carlos is Lord
that would that would make sense
thanks for the Super Chat from Brock who
says what do you think of the intro
being added to the series and it having
the Game of Thrones theme music I think
it's a bit lame that they just reused
the theme music instead of creating a
cool new piece of music to be the theme
I think it's a bit obvious it's a bit
cowardly to just reuse it like that and
I do kind of dislike just the aesthetic
of like whizzing around in this
grape Stone 3D model like I don't know
it doesn't look great to me but the
symbolism of like the blood Lane and
like the nodes representing the Kings
and the family tree we'll explain that
in the uh video that we're gonna make uh
this week so like And subscribe and
press the Bell
um and yeah I don't I don't love the
opening sequence personally
thanks for the Super Chat from kiosk
ballerina who says I think Corliss is
saying house for larion is symbolically
the second son to House Targaryen yeah
that's a good point
um because he talks about the valerians
being sort of like underdogs like they
never got to ride dragons they had to
make their own power using the power of
ships and sailing and stuff and I also
like how Corliss acknowledged luck is is
part of how the valerians have risen to
power I think that's you know lots of
people who quote unquote succeed uh like
to take all the credit for it but I
think that luck is relevant too
um what else haven't we talked about we
talked about the death of Ryan and
rhaenyra choosing uh Kristen Cole to
join the kingsguard uh partly because he
has the motor combat experience and I
think on some level partly because uh
she thinks he's hot
um Dragon stone is traditionally the
seat of the heir to the throne and
that's why it's so provocative that
Daemon has just taken over it
um thanks for the Super Chat from
astroblue who says what is your current
power ratings
uh I don't know what you mean do you
mean like what the most powerful people
in the story is
uh well that's you know between viserys
Otto and and and
uh call us and Daemon I suppose
um we talked about the new sept we
talked about uh Alison and Rainier's
conversation
um we talked about the seven and the
faith
and the loss of the mothers
uh we talked about you know viserys has
such good intentions
we talked about the Lena scene and
Lena's interest in vegar is really cool
the ominous dark sign the viserys's hand
is infected by the throne
we talked about
rainieres
yeah a sense of almost like jealousy
from rainey's towards Rainier that you
know she's the heir and I feel like
rainy's almost doesn't want Rainier to
succeed you know but um she also is
sympathetic and almost like a mentor at
the same time and the theme of
patriarchy rejecting women as rulers
we talked about Alison's fidgeting we
talked about daemon's gigantic balls
stealing a dragon egg taking a second
wife
I guess that's all canceled now uh now
that he's decided to run off to the
stepstones instead
uh and you know Daemon specifically
stole one of the eggs of the Dragon
dream fire specifically the one that was
going to be baby balon's egg so it sort
of is itself a symbol of being the heir
of the throne
we talked about how Otto is so
overbearing and seems more in charge
than viserys does
I liked how you know the first thing
or one of the first things that Daemon
said when Otto turned up was like
where's viserys
because like Daemon is not interested in
just pissing off autosomal like he he
did this this is a cry for attention
like he's been languishing on
Dragonstone for six months he wants his
brother to acknowledge Him He wants to
he wants a viserys to acknowledge Him
and that's I think why he did this
um thanks for the Super Chat from
wealthwolf who says I'm enjoying Matt
Smith's Daemon his outbursts seem far
more motivated by a need for approval
rather than a lost for power he has a
sadness to him yeah I uh I agree with
that and that's what they've said in
interviews thanks to the donation from
Phil to Fresh who says any chance of the
many-faced Gods making an appearance
I I'm not going to spoil anything but um
I wouldn't expect to see too much of the
faceless man in the house of black and
white
um
I we got to learn about Missouri's
backstory as sort of sounds like she's
been like enslaved and exploited
um it was cool to see rhaenyra getting
some [ __ ] done you know everyone was
telling her to shut up and pour the wine
but she comes out here and gets results
and resolves this conflict peacefully
next to the Super Chat from shivendra
who says how do you show us preview
um there's a there's a system it's a bit
technical uh but thank you shivendra
um and it's funny that you know viserys
deciding to marry Allison is like the
one time he asserts himself and it is uh
it pisses off everybody and was maybe a
terrible idea I thought it was really
interesting that you know like viserys
didn't know that rhaenyra flew off to
Dragonstone and back like like Rainier
returned to Dragonstone and someone told
viserys oh she's back and viserys is
like she left
like like no one tells viserys things
and that's similar to in the previous
episode
when Daemon got into the red cape and
got onto the Iron Throne without viserys
knowing Harold told us that the king
doesn't know so it's like viserys is not
in charge he doesn't have his house in
order like people don't tell him stuff
people go off and do their own thing
people disobey him like no one respects
his authority and that's a problem
um
we talked about how in the books
rhaenyra is not upset about Alison
marrying viserys because they have an
age difference and they're not best
friends in the books
um I liked that anyone was Defensive of
viserys
yeah okay
um we're gonna end up this uh live
stream shortly if you've got any like
final questions that you're desperate uh
for us to talk about let me know but I
think we will now look at the on the
next episode bit
so if you don't want to see the on the
next episode preview that HBO put out
you might want to avert your gaze now
um but we're going to look at that now
so this is the Inside the episode thing
uh I think we sort of talked about most
before they covered there and where's
the on the next episode
it's after this isn't it
oh it is
instead before the Inside the episode
huh
yeah here we go all right here's the
preview of The Next Episode
and it's it's kind of spicy so
uh
aegon will be king Otto says so you know
spoilers for The Next Episode spoilers
for episode three but we're doing
another time skip we're jumping ahead
and viserys and Allison have had a baby
the firstborn son of the king uh this is
him this is little baby aegon Targaryen
uh who is the son of viserys and Allison
um and Otto was saying that this kid
aegon will be the king of Westeros
um which you know replaces Rainier uh
rhaenyra was supposed to be the air and
everyone bowed to her and said she would
be the heir but now this kid aegon is
replacing her and Rainier does not look
very happy about that
um and yeah you will be with your own
child eventually so
this is just like you know rhaenyra in
episode one was saying I don't want to
make babies I want to be a knight or I
want to rule or whatever uh and so now
she's being pushed back into that role
that she never wanted in the first place
um and Alison is saying it doesn't need
to be this way so maybe she's saying
like you know we can be friends still
but I think conflict is rising uh
right near a rides off somewhere she's
rebelling she's escaping there's a scene
where she seems to get like attacked by
something which is interesting uh and
then we see crab feeder crack ass crab
feeder on the step Stones call us and
Daemon are gonna go and fight him call
us looking amazing and some armor
uh Alma looks really cool so it looks
like Daemon and Corliss are going to a
war against the crab feeder
um viserys is stabbing something with a
spear there's like a
bloody spear here so I guess like some
animal or some Beast attacks Rainier and
like viserys saves her with a spear
maybe uh maybe it's the same pig that uh
the same pig that kills King Robert
Baratheon in Game of Thrones crabs will
soon dine on all of us so it sounds like
the um
war against crab feeder does not go very
well I like that they've got actual crab
claws as as the little uh symbols the
pieces representing uh the triakies men
uh so we get a big battle we get some
like triarchy Bowman so these are guys
from Mir release or tyrosh those Eastern
cities looks like Daemon gets hit by an
arrow uh which uh will suck and then a
dragon turns up and burns everything
curraxis uh which you know I I think it
did start to feel like a bit repetitive
in the show when you know there'd be
some battle and it starts going badly
but then the dragon turns up and turns
the tide of battle like I feel like that
happened a lot of times
and that also happens a lot of times in
the books as well uh it's always going
one way then the dragons turn off and
the dragons settle the matter but uh
there will be more surprises ahead I
don't doubt but uh yeah like they are
moving at a pretty fast clip in terms of
the pace and in terms of the timeline uh
like we must be jumping like at least
like a year uh forwards in episode three
introducing baby aegon and baby aegon
looks great he looks like a Targaryen
with his blonde hair and his fancy
outfit look at these little
Royal Toddler clothes that's great maybe
this woman is a um a uh what are they
called uh you know the the milk mother
who like breastfeeds the kid and
whatever
um so yeah look I'm I'm excited for the
next episode
um please do like and subscribe and
press the like and press the Bell so you
get notified
um
and consider getting a free copy of the
book Fire and Blood at audible.com ASX
wetness yeah that's that's it
um
you can go and check out our sponsor get
a free copy of Fire and Blood or the
world of ice and fire if you sign up for
a free trial at audible.com ASX you can
cancel the trial afterwards and still
keep the free book
um helvet says how long did it take Otto
and his party to get to Dragonstone yeah
it's a good question I mean I don't
think it would take very long because
it's not it's not very far to get from
King's Landing to Dragonstone
um King's Landing is here and
Dragonstone is here which is just past
uh driftmark which is here which is
where the valerions are based
um so yeah I don't know is that a few
days is that is that a few hours I don't
really know I don't think it's a big
deal either way again like don't get too
caught up on the timeline I think there
will be times when the timeline might
not make perfect sense because they are
compressing 30 years into one season and
you know they might have to do some
[ __ ] things with the timeline but I
think that you know it will make more
sense than the goddamn jet packs in uh
Game of Thrones season eight
um
yeah so uh thanks for participating
everyone there will be a explained video
proper edited video essay about the
episode soon
um
and yeah thanks for joining in
life of shoe says lovely work
yeah cool all right see you next time
guys
cheers oh I think I think the next video
will be out Friday
um we got it out Friday last week so I
think you know we're aiming for each
explained video to come out on Friday
um got some creative synonyms for
wetness in the chat unfortunately crabs
in the chat
um you might like to subscribe to the
alt shift X podcast which is uh there's
some like interviews and chats there I'd
like to do some more
uh conversations with other Game of
Thrones people
um but uh you know time is limited
during the house of the Dragon season so
we'll see what we can do but uh yeah
excited for more thanks for
participating and see you in the next
one cheers